BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEES FIRST REGULAR RATHER
REGULARLY SCHEDULED BILL HEARING
FOR THIS YEAR. WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THROUGHOUT THE
BUILDING SORT OF- SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESSES CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALLING NUMBER THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE. IS. ONE
EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO
ZERO. AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO
ZERO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON TV. IF YOU
WERE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. WE WILL BE
LIMITING TESTIMONY TO TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES PER BILL.
HUMAN TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS.
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AND THEN STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I ALSO
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION THAT LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE WE HAVE TWELVE ITEMS TO
CONSIDER TODAY INCLUDING THREE
BALLS ON CONSENT- AND WITH THAT
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE
GONNA GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- AND I WANT TO INVITE
DOCTOR WEBER UP TO PRESENT- AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO. SHORT
WITNESS CAN GET BACK TO SCHOOL.
SCHOOL IS IMPORTANT. NO TRUANCY.
THE MORNING CARE ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO
THE RESTROOM ACCESS ACT WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DIAGNOSED WITH CROHN'S
DISEASE OR ULCERATIVE COLITIS
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO AN EMPLOYEE
RESTROOM IF THERE IS NOT ONE
THAT IS READILY AVAILABLE. THERE
ARE OVER THREE POINT ONE MILLION
ADULTS LIVING IN THE UNITED
STATES WITH CROHN'S DISEASE OR
ULCERATIVE COLITIS. COLLECTIVELY
THESE CONDITIONS ARE KNOWN AS
INFLAMMATORY BOWEL DISEASE. I.
B. D. IS A CHRONIC INFLAMMATION
OF ONE'S INTESTINES LEADING TO
SYMPTOMS SUCH AS SEVERE
ABDOMINAL PAIN AND DIARRHEA.
THESE INDIVIDUALS OFTEN SUFFER
FROM DEBILITATING URGENCY TO USE
THE RESTROOM IMMEDIATELY OR RISK
HAVING AN EMBARRASSING ACCIDENT
. IN TWO THOUSAND FOR A FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD BY THE NAME OF ALY BAIN
WAS IN A DEPARTMENT STORE WITH
HER MOTHER. IN ILLINOIS SHE HAD
BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH IBD AT THE
AGE OF ELEVEN AND WHILE IN THAT
DEPARTMENT STORE ALLEY
EXPERIENCED A SUDDEN URGE TO USE
THE RESTROOM AND WAS DENIED
ACCESS TO A RESTAURANT BY THE
DEPARTMENT STORE. THAT RESULTED
IN HER HAVING AN EMBARRASSING
ACCIDENT. SHE TOOK THIS
INITIATIVE TO ADVOCATE FOR
HERSELF AND THOSE WHO REMAIN
SILENT WHILE SUFFERING FROM
THESE MEDICAL CONDITIONS BECAUSE
OF EMBARRASSMENT. AND A TWO
THOUSAND FIVE. THE ILLINOIS
STATE LEGISLATOR PASSED THE
RESTROOM ACCESS ACT ALSO KNOWN
AS ALLEYS LAW WHICH PROVIDED
THOSE WITH A MEDICAL EMERGENCY
TO BE ALLOWED ACCESS TO AN
EMPLOYEE ONLY RESTROOM. SINCE
THEN FIFTEEN OTHER STATES HAVE
PASSED SIMILAR LAWS INCLUDING
COLORADO KENTUCKY OHIO TEXAS NEW
YORK AND MICHIGAN. AND IF PASSED
HERE CALIFORNIA WOULD BE THE
SIXTEENTH STATE. AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY TO ENSURE ACCESS TO A
RESTROOM FOR CUSTOMERS WHO
PERCENT A CERTIFIED CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DOCUMENT SIGNED BY A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL ATTESTING THAT THE
CUSTOMER USES AN OSTOMY DEVICE.
HAS CROHN'S DISEASE ULCERATIVE
COLITIS OR ANOTHER INFLAMMATORY
BOWEL DISEASE OR MEDICAL
CONDITION REQUIRING ACCESS TO A
TOILET FACILITY IMMEDIATELY. THE
CROHN'S AND COLITIS FOUNDATION
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND HERE TO
SPEAK WITH ME ON THIS BILL TODAY
IS DR SMITA MALARD ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF THE PERMANENCY
MEDICAL GROUP. AND ASHLYN
SALZBURG A YOUNG LADY WHO LIVES
IN ADVOCATES FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
IBD THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
WEBBER- AND- OUR DOCTOR LORD AND
ASSELIN TESTIFIED BY PHONE I
THINK RATES ARE WE GO TO THE
PHONE LINES TO FIND DR LARD. AND
THEN ASKED IN SALZBURG. TWO
MINUTES- FOR. PER PERSON PLEASE. LASSEN. WE HAVE EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR ON THE LINE. YOU'LL
LEARN. YOU WILL LEARN. ALL RIGHT
PLEASE HOLD FOR TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES.
AT&T OPERATOR CAN YOU HEAR ME.
THAT EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR I'M
NOT EVEN SURE YEAH YEAH. THAT.
ALL RIGHTS. BEAR WITH US. OKAY-
LIKE TECH SUPPORT.
YEAH WHEN WE.
SO WE'RE GONNA DO WHAT WE FIGURE
OUT THE PHONE LINES WHEN WE GO
TO A ARE THERE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM WANT TO TESTIFY COME ON UP-
TWO MINUTES PER FROM AWARENESS
AND WHATEVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH YOU CAN COME TO THE TABLE
YOU CAN DO IT THERE WHATEVER YOU
WANT. ON BEHALF OF THE SINCE
WHERE POSSIBLE. TESTING PERFECT
- GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BRUCE
ROBERT MATURE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO FIRST LET ME
LEAD OFF BY SAYING WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ENGAGING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE WERE SYMPATHETIC
TO THE GOALS AND THE MECHANISM
OF USING AN ID CARD THAT'S
MEDICALLY APPROVED WE THINK
THAT'S ALL A GOOD SOLUTION- WE
ARE WE ARE THE OTHER STATES LAWS
IN THIS AREA AND WE ONLY- WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE IMMENSE
TAKEN LAST WEEK TO ADDRESS KIND
OF MANY OF THE CORE ISSUES
WITHIN THEIR TWO SMALL TWEAKS
THAT REMAIN AND WE ARE IN CLOSE
CONTACT WITH THE ATHOR'S OFFICE
TO ADDRESS THESE. PARTICULARLY
ON THE FOCUS OF THE BREATH OF
THIS BILL WHAT OTHER STATES ARE
FOCUSED ON RETAILERS ONLY ON
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD AFFECT
BUSINESSES MUCH MORE BROADLY SO
WE'RE HOPING TO REALLY FIX
ISSUES RELATED TO THAT BREATH-
AGAIN LOOK I REALLY ENJOYED THE
ENGAGEMENT AND HELPING TO
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS SOON THANK
YOU RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WHAT ONE MORE
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. NOT
SEEING ANY. J. IN ON THE TECH
TEAM. STILL WORKING ON IT ANY-
ADD ON'S OF ME TO USE- EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM ANYONE WANNA. ME TOO IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. NOPE. IT
WORKED AT SEVEN O'CLOCK LAST
NIGHT ALL NOT SURE WAS EVIDENT
BUT A COUPLE OF US ARE RIGHT
HERE AVENSIS LAUGHS YEAH. WHAT A.
I THINK YOU NEED TO UNPLUG IT
FROM THE WALL AND THEN PLUG IT
BACK IN. AS ALWAYS THE FIRST
STEP.
THE FOR PATIENTS DR WEBER. WE
WANNA.
YEAH.
DR WEBER WE'RE GONNA DID SET
YOUR BILL ASIDE FOR A MINUTE.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
WILL COME BACK TO IT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE ONCE THE PHONES ARE
WORKING AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON-
SOMEONE BRAG. WHO'S WITH ARE IN
THE ROOM SOUNDS GOOD THANKS
THANKS. ALL RIGHT AS A MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY WITH. THE GREAT
BILL AB. SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX. WE
SEEM TO THINK SO. WHEN I BUY IT
YEAH. FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
APPRECIATED. CHAIRMAN BERMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX LEGISLATION
THAT CLARIFIES THAT THE ADULT
USE CANNABIS INITIATIVE PASSED
BY CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE MEDICINAL
AND ADULT USE CANNABIS
REGULATION SAFETY ACT. DOES NOT
PROHIBIT A DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LICENSEE FOR
MANUFACTURING DISTRIBUTING OR
SELLING PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN
INDUSTRIAL HEMP HEMP OR CANNABIS
NOITES EXTRACTS OR DERIVATIVES
FROM INDUSTRIAL HEMP. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS THE
LARGEST CBD MARKET IN UNITED
STATES DESPITE PASSAGE OF AB
FORTY FIVE LAST YEAR THERE ARE
STILL QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT IS
LEGAL AND WHO CAN PRODUCE CBD
PRODUCTS IN THIS NOON MARKET
PLACE. A REST A RECENTLY ISSUED
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH FAQ HAS
FURTHER MUDDIED THE WATERS BY
INCORRECTLY STATING THAT OUT OF
STATE MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO REGISTER IN
CALIFORNIA. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX
REPRESENT A REFINEMENT OF LAST
YEAR'S LEGISLATION AB FORTY FIVE
TO FURTHER OUTLINE IT DEFINED
AND STABLE REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT ENVIRONMENT FOR
LICENSE CBD PRODUCTS IN THE
STATE. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX ALSO
STATES LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO
EVENTUALLY ENHANCE THE VIABILITY
OF CANNABIS LICENSEES IN THE
MARKETPLACE BY PURSUING MEASURES
TO RELIEVE TAX AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS AND TO AUTHORIZE
LICENCES TO MANUFACTURE
DISTRIBUTE AND SELL HAVE BEEN
KIND OF ANNOYED. PRODUCTS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH CURRENT LAW. WE
EAGERLY AWAIT THE RELEASE BY
JULY ONE OF REPORT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
THAT WHAT OUTLINED THE NEEDED
STEPS TO INCORPORATE HIM INTO
THE CANNABIS SUPPLY CHAIN. I
ANTICIPATE THIS BILL WILL BE
AMENDED IN LIGHT OF THAT REPORT
AND UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY WISH TO HEAR THIS
BILL AGAIN IN THE FINAL FORM
WHEN IT COMES BACK TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR CONCURRENCE. I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT WITNESSES
TODAY'S RAM MARTIN REPRESENTING
THAT U. S. HEMP ROUNDTABLE AND
AMY JENKINS REVERSING CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. VERY NICE TO BE
HERE TODAY- I WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR AND STAFF TO BEGIN
WITH FOR THEIR TIRELESS EFFORTS
TO ESTABLISH A LEGAL FRAMEWORK
FOR THE LAWFUL MANUFACTURE. AND
SALE OF HEMP DERIVED PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA.AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX
REPRESENTS THE NEXT PHASE IN
THIS MULTI YEAR PROCESS
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL CLARIFIES
THAT BUSINESSES AND POSSESSION
OF A COMMERCIAL CANNABIS LICENSE
MAY ALSO MANUFACTURE DISTRIBUTE
AND SELL HEMP PRODUCTS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH EXISTING LAW.
THE CIA HAS LONG SUPPORTED A
CANNABIS LICENSEES ABILITY TO
INTEGRATE HEMP INTO THE CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN SPECIFICALLY WE
SUPPORT THE INTEGRATION OF HEMP
CANNABINOIDS INTO MANUFACTURED
PRODUCTS. THE ABILITY TO
MANUFACTURE THESE PRODUCTS AND
THE SAME FACILITY AND THE
ABILITY TO SELL THESE PRODUCTS.
THE CIA AND COALITION PARTNERS
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE FORTHCOMING
REPORT WHICH WILL OUTLINE THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO ALLOW THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. TO ACT. GAUGE
AND IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND BE
PART OF THE- AND INTEGRATE THE
TWO THE TWO PRODUCTS IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
SPELL AND URGE YOUR PASSAGE
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MS JENKINS. I THINK YOU NEED
TO HIT A BUTTON SOMEWHERE. MIKE
UNIFLORA LIGHTS UP THOMAS. I
RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE U.
S. HEMP ROUNDTABLE AS WELL AS
THE PARENT COMPANY WHICH IS A
LARGE CANNABIS- MANUFACTURER AND
RETAILER IN CALIFORNIA- WHEN WE
WERE NEGOTIATING AB FORTY FIVE
LAST LAST SESSION WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT REMAIN WAS THE
INTEGRATION OF CANNABIS
LICENSEES INTO THE HEMP SUPPLY
CHAIN- IT WAS DECIDED AT THE END
THAT THE QUESTION OF HOW NEED TO
STILL BE ANSWERED NOT WHETHER
BUT HOW- THE LANGUAGE WAS
WRITTEN INTO AB FORTY FIVE
SPECIFICALLY TO FOCUS ON THE
HOW. AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE SOME
COMPLICATIONS AND SPECIALLY IN
MANUFACTURING ABOUT HOW YOU A
RECTIFIER WALL BETWEEN CANNABIS
MANUFACTURING AND HAMP BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IT CAN BE DONE
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF FIGURING
OUT STATUTORILY HOW TO DO THAT
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD AS
WELL TO THE REPORT COMING OUT ON
JULY FIRST I'M WHICH IS GOING TO
TELL US HOW NOT WHETHER I'M TO
INTEGRATE- AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS BILL BEING AMENDED AT THAT
POINT TO REFLECT THAT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
THANK A SMART- SO I BUILT. UP
THE PHONE LINES WORKING AZNABLE
- ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PRIMER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. BUT I YEARS YEAH-
OKAY ANY I DON'T WANT TO ADD ON
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL TO DO IT
ALL IN A GROUP THIS TIME ANYBODY
IN THE HEARING ROOM WANT TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT. NOPE ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINES I THINK THE
PHONE WHAT THE HARD RESET WORKED
I THINK THE PHONE LINES ARE
WORKING. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
ARE YOU THERE. I AM MISTER CHAIR
. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN JUST ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE
EXPECTING ANYONE. OKAY WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I'M
SORRY LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JOE TO BIND WITH PARTNER VISORS
ON BEHALF OF THE CANOPY GROWTH
CORPORATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. YEAH THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS POINT
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES
FOR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO NO
MOTIONS. YET BUT- ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. I DON'T SEE ANY- MS
AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
. IS IT WILL MAKE THAT EVEN
EASIER I WOULD JUST SIMPLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE AND YOU KNOW WE ALL
THINK OUR BILLS ARE PERFECT THIS
IS GOING TO FINE TUNE IT SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE ABOUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. FOR
THAT BREVITY AND FOR THE
OPENNESS- AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR I KNOW THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT YOU HAVE LIGHT ON FOR
SEVERAL YEARS. NOW AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSISTENCE
THERE ARE MANY STRONG ARGUMENTS
FOR INTEGRATING HEMP HEMP INTO
THE CANNABIS SUPPLY CHAIN BUT I
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL AS DRAFTED
ISN'T REALLY DOING THAT YET BUT
THAT IT WOULD POTENTIALLY BE
AMENDED LATER IN THE YEAR ONCE
WE RECEIVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL- I'D ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE ENGAGING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND YOU MENTIONED YOU
WOULD I APPRECIATE THAT. IN
ANTICIPATION OF US HEARING THE
BILL AGAIN ON CONCURRENCE WHEN
THE BILL IS MORE WORKED OUT- IN
THE MEANTIME I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THAT ARE MOVING THE BILL
FOR TODAY. WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT. THANKS SO MUCH APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU. SO LET'S LET
DOCTOR WEBER. GO BACK UP NOW
THAT THE PHONE LINES ARE WORKING
AND WILL. CONTINUE WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION. AND SO I BELIEVE
WE WERE AT THE POINT OF LOOKING
FOR DR RUE LARD AND ASSELIN
SALZBURG VIA WITNESS TESTIMONY
BY PHONES OR EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD HELP US
FIND DOCTOR REAL ART AND THEN
ASHLAND SALZBURG FOR- SUPPORT
TESTIMONY AND NOW WE'RE BACK ON
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO- BY DOCTOR
WEBER. IF YOUR NAME WAS JUST
CALLED WOULD YOU PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO THAT IDENTIFY YOURSELF
BECAUSE WOULD YOU PLEASE.
THEY ARE NOT ON THE LINE SIR YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. GIVE US
ONE SECOND THINGS GOT A LITTLE
COMPLICATED. WITH THE EARLIER
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. DR LORD
OUR ASSN SALZBURG IF YOU'RE
THERE SORRY OPERATOR IT'S EASE
WAS A PRESS ONE ZERO. BUT THEY
DID EAT YES IT'D ACCOMPANISTS
OUTDATED ACCOMPANISTS- HOSTS AND
SOME ASKING THEM TO DATA BY
THEMSELVES ARE PRESSING ONE ZERO
PERFECT. SO IN THE MEANTIME WE
HAVE A QUORUM IF NOBODY'S LEFT
YET BUT PEOPLE MODEL. ON ONCE
AGAIN. SOMEONE MUST TAKE A BACK. WE GOT A QUORUM SO QUICKLY
CALL THE ROLL WHILE HOPEFULLY
DOCTOR LORD AND ASTEN SALZBURGER
ABLE TO CALL IN- WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. YOUR. BONTA. RT OUR.
YEAH WARD. YEAH. GREAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM. OKAY OKAY- SO TRY ONE
MORE TIME DR RULE LORD OR ASIN
SALZBURG IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
PRESS ONE ZERO SO THE EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR CAN NOTICE YOU AND-
YOU CAN TESTIFYING IF NOT WE
MIGHT CONTINUE- WITH THE
PRESENTATION. IN ORDER TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES RESEARCHER
OKAY SO LET'S CONTINUE LET ME.
GO AHEAD THIS IS FAIR WITH ME
AND SOMEONE MAY HAVE JOINED HERE
JUST BEAR WITH ME TAKE YOUR TIME
. THEY GOT A MOTION. LOOKING FOR
A SECOND GOT A SECOND.
OKAY SO I THINK OPERATOR WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD
TO GET SOMEBODY JUST INTERRUPT
AND LET ME KNOW- BUT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE FOR WITH THE PRESENTATION
SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK WELL I GUESS IT IS OR
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY. IN IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AS ADD ON IS A ME TOO
. LET'S OPEN IT UP. IN ORDER IF
YOU'D LIKE TO A- KPTI TOOK A
COMMENT PRESS ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND WE DO HAVE SOME QUEUING UP
AT THIS POINT MISTER CHAIR.
PERFECT READY WHEN YOU ARE. OKAY.
OKAY THE FIRST COMEDIES FROM
LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS RYAN ELAINE WOULD
BE CALIFORNIA RETAILER
ASSOCIATION AND I DECIDED TO
CALL IN TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION- WITH EVERYTHING
ABOUT ME THANK YOU. AUTHORS
FAVORITE WORDS RIGHT THERE. OKAY
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER COMMON
FELINE- THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THERE MY NAME IS
REBECCA TURNING AND I'M A
CURRENT PATIENT WHO VOLUNTEERED
FOR THE CROHN'S AND COLITIS
FOUNDATION AND I SUPPOSE HIGH ET
AT SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS RESEARCHER. AND
GUESTS WILL BRING BACK TO
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. PLEASE I JUST HAVE ONE
MY CONCERN IS IN REGARDS TO THE
BUSINESSES AND A GREAT BILL
HELLO BUT IF YOU COME INTO MY
THIS IS A AUTOMOTIVE SHOP IT'S
IN THE BACK OF THE BUILDING MY
EMPLOYEES ARE COVERED THROUGH
WORKERS COMP OF SOME HAPPENS BUT
HERE I'M BEING A NICE PERSON
ALLOWING YOU ARE SOMETHING
HAPPENS IN THE LIABILITY FACTOR
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN WORK
THAT OUT- IN THE COMMENTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION
WE'VE ACTUALLY ALREADY WORK THAT
OUT WITH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
THAT- CAME OUT ACTUALLY AFTER
THE CHAMBERS LETTER CAME OUT. SO
LIKE THEY STATED WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM BUT THAT
LIABILITY ISSUE HAS ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED PERFECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MR GRAYSON. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS REALLY GOOD
BILL. IT'S GOING TO REALLY HELP
A LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SEEING NONE DR WEBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO IT'S LONG OVERDUE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN OUR SISTER
STATES IN PROVIDING ACCESS TO
THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE RISK. OF HAVING
AN EMBARRASSING ACCIDENT WHILE
THEY'RE OUT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR WEBBER- AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. I BELIEVE THAT
MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
BY YOUR- RECENT AMENDMENTS. AND
ENCOURAGE YOU JUST WANT
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON ANY OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS WHICH- IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU DEFINITELY WILL. AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY- AND CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE VOTE. CONFIRMING MY
MICROPHONE IS ON SOUNDS GOOD.
AYE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THAT HEALTH COMMITTEE BERMAN HI
BERMAN HI FLORA. BLOOM LAMB I
BONTA CHAN CHAN I. FONG I'M NOT
VOTING GIPSON MASON GRAYSON I
IRWIN ME MCCARTY INA SALAS SALAS
AYE AYES SMITH SMITH ALL WRITING
. WARD WEBER. HOWEVER I. SO WILL
. LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS AT
ON AS THEY COME IN AND I DO WANT
TO NOTE- SUMMER SMITH THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY SITTING IN-
TO REPLACE WHEN YOUR CALL IS
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED US NUMBER
WARD WILL WILL THAT WILL
WILL AS WELL AT SOME POINT SO
NEXT LET'S MOVE ON I THINK TO
MISTER LOWE. I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
. ELSE IS NOT ON THE COMMITTEE-
SKEWS ME. I APOLOGIZE MISTER
LOAD STARTED WORK AT AND SEE
THEIR. I'M GOING TO PRESENT- AB. SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN. AND I
THINK IT WILL JUST MAKE SURE
THERE'S A BUTTON ON YOUR LEFT.
THE. THIS IS LEE THAT ONE-
PROBLEM. WE'RE ALL SET PLEASE
WRITE TO THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND CONGRATULATIONS- MR
BERMAN ON BECOMING CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN STRENGTHENS THE
STATE ABILITY TO DISCIPLINE
LICENSE CONTRACTORS WHO FAIL TO
COMPLY WITH BUILDING PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS. FAILING TO OBTAIN
A PERMIT IS A SERIOUS VIOLATION
. EGYPT'S NOT INSTALLED UP TO
CODE PLACE OWNERS AT RISK AND
CAN PREVENT CONSUMERS FROM
ACHIEVING ENERGY SAVINGS. AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
THESE ISSUES BY PROVIDING THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY TO
DISCIPLINE LICENSE. THAT FAIL TO
COMPLY WITH PERMIT REQUIREMENTS
AS WELL AS OTHER HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS THANK THE
CIVIL CIVIL PENALTIES FOR THESE
VIOLATIONS AND CLARIFYING THE
LICENSEE FAILING TO OBTAIN A
BIRD. BUILDING PERMIT IS A
CHARGEABLE VIOLATION HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS MICHAEL A
JAM THAT SKI CHIEF OF
LEGISLATION FOR THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD RIGHT HERE
MISTER DIRECT YOU WHEN YOU'RE
READY IT TWO MINUTES GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS. MY
JANISKEE WITH THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD THE BOARD IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS MEASURE
L. IT AROSE OUT OF AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE CONTRACTOR COMPLIANCE
WITH H. FAX STANDARD AS IT
RELATES TO CLEAN ENERGY
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BUILDING
CODE OF COURSE IT'S ALREADY OF
VIOLATION FOR A CONTRACTOR IN
EXISTING LAW TO NOT COMPLY WITH
STATE OR LOCAL BUILDING CODES
AFFABLE TO THEIR PROJECT. SO
WITH THIS BILL WILL DO IS
CLARIFY THAT THAT IS A VIOLATION
OF THE LAW AND ALSO PLACE THAT
VIOLATION OF THE HIGHER TIER OF
CSFB VIOLATIONS ALONG WITH OTHER
SAFETY SAFETY AND HEALTH CODES
APPLICABLES THE CONTRACTORS TO
REFLECT THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
VIOLATION. THAT IS THE
BACKGROUND ON THE MATTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND PLEASE LET ME
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ANYBODY WANT TO ADD ON.
NEED TO KNOW ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. NOT SEEING ANY I
SHOULD APOLOGIZE IT'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND THE- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
ASK PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YEAH WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE SOME QUEUING UP HERE
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU.
OKAY THE FIRST COMMENT IS FROM
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
RATING- NUMBER HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BUT THE NEXT TIME IT IS
FROM LINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. I'M SORRY I DID I
THOUGHT IS THIS I THOUGHT THIS
WAS A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
WE DO NOT- WE DO HAVE AN AB
AGENTS OR ANY FOR THAT IT HAS
NOT. BEEN PRESENTED YET SO
THEY'LL BE PRESENTED A LITTLE
BIT. YEAH SORRY OKAY THE NEXT
COVERED HIS FROM LINE SIXTEEN
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU IT
SKIPPED ALONG WITH THE AMERICAN
SUBCONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
COMPRISED OF HUNDREDS OF UNION
AND MERIT SHOP COMPANIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
FOR SAFETY REASONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING
IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MOTIONS OR
SECONDS ON AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN. GOT A MOTION GOT A
BIPARTISAN SECOND. NO QUESTIONS
NO COMMENTS OUR RECORD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK YOU
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION THE
SPONSOR IS THE STATE LICENSE
BOARD. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU DR
CORRIGAN I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT PERMIT
COMPLIANCE. WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR WORKERS OCCUPANTS
IN BUILDING OWNERS I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN. BERMAN AYE FLORA BLOOM.
M. I. BONTA CHAN CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM FONG. FONG I GIPSON
GRAYSON I- IRWIN ME MCCARTY
MEDINA SALAS SALAS I SMITH. IF
I'D TANG WARD WEBER HOWEVER I
BELIEVE THAT RIGHT WILL BE THAT
OPEN HOUSE MEMBERS THANK YOU
DON'T OF COURSE THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. NOW MR LOW. WITH
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
FIFTY FIVE. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD. THE FIFTY FIVE
WHICH WE WORKED ON IN PREVIOUS
YEARS WITH RESPECT TO THE CURES
DATABASE THIS IS DEALING WITH
THE OPIOID CRISIS AND INSTEAD OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AS
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THIS SHOULD BE
VIEWED IN THE LANDS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AND THIS IS WHAT THIS UP
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS ABOUT TO
HELP INSURE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING IT AND TACKLING IT
WITH RESPECT TO A PUBLIC HEALTH.
ALLIANCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
LOW AND WE HAVE A MOTION. OPEN
TO A SECOND. GOT A SECOND. AND I
BELIEVE- MS SANCHEZ FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IS HERE TO PRESENT IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING POLICE SANCHEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I'M WERE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND- DO YOU ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW MENTIONED. THE BILL
IS INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT CURES
IS ADMINISTERED IN A WAY THAT
SUPPORTS A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE TO THE OPIOID CRISIS
WHEN CARE WAS A- WELL THE
PRECURSOR CURRENT CURES AS-
ARTICULATED IN THE VERY.
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS AND- IN
THE THIRTY WAS REALLY ABOUT
LAUNCH BUT TIME ARE PRO TO
DEALING WITH. I'M CONTROLLED.
AND USE DISORDERS HAS. CHANGED
AND SHIFTED AND THIS WILL ENSURE
THE- OF THE DATABASE RE- HEALTH
FOLKS. I OVER TO AS A SEEN THE
IMPLEMENT OF CARE IS OVER YEARS
- TO THE HAVE VALUED IT AT A-
TOOL. IT NEEDS TO. IN A SPACE TO
ALLOW THEM. A WORKS. AND MAKES
THE IN IS READY AND OF. WHEN
CLINICIANS AND WE THINK MOVING
TO- AND EACH THAT MORE OF HEALTH
FOLK. WHAT ENSURE THAT THEY LOSE
SECOND. ARE MADE AND SO- AGAIN
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY. SEEING NONE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY. MISTER
FLOOR WALKED IN AT THE MOMENT IS
VERY OMINOUS I DON'T THINK HE'S
OPPOSITION I DON'T KNOW IT MIGHT
BE- ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. LET'S GOTO PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATIONS ON THE LINES IF YOU
TO GIVE YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR RIGHT. BACK TO CALL-
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS COMMENTS I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. A QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES. HELLO MISTER
WARD WE THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
MISTER WARD THANK YOU MISTER-
ARE GOING TO BE SOMETHING IN
TODAY MY ONLY QUESTION WAS WITH
REGARD TO A DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. YOU KNOW TO BE
CARETAKERS OF THE SYSTEM FOR
SOME TIME- I KNOW THAT THEY
HAVEN'T REGISTERED ANY OPINION
ON THE MATTER- AND I'M
WONDERING- AND I KNOW THAT- IS
TO BE DETERMINED WORKED OUT. AT
THERE'S A MORE APPROPRIATE
AGENCY THAT'S GOING TO WORK ON
THIS- BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY
INSIGHT AS TO WHETHER DOJ WOULD
BE THAT SUPERIOR AGENCY DO THEY
WANT TO RELINQUISH THIS
RESPONSIBILITY HOW MIGHT THIS.
ACTUALLY PLAY OUT YEAH DID THEY
GIVE YOU MUCH WELL AS A YOU
WILL- CAN SEE IN THE COMMISSION
ALICE'S AS WELL TO- THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
MENTOR WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES IN WHICH THE LOCATION OF
THE CURES IS IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND OR HUMAN SERVICES
SO WE'RE ENGAGING CONVERSATION
WITH THEM. ALL THE WAY THROUGH
AND THAT WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
FIND SOME AGREEMENT AS TO THE
BEST LOCATION A COMMITTER WITH
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL. IN
COLLABORATION. RIGHT THANK YOU
SIR ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THING NINE IS ON OVER
LOW WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE MY
FAVORITE CLOTHES THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
STILL SOME DETAILS TO WORK OUT
ON THIS BILL I KNOW YOU'LL
REMAIN PERSISTENT IN SEEKING
INPUT FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AND I
INVITE YOU TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE. IN THE
MEANTIME AND WITH THAT IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO- FOR JUST AN AYE
VOTE ON THE BILL- MISTER
SATURDAY PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
BERMAN. AYE BERMAN AYE FLORA.
FLOOR AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I BONTA.
GEN. CHEN I CUNNINGHAM. FONG I'M
NOT VOTING GIPSON GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE IRWIN LEE MCCARTY
MEDINA SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH
NONVOTING TANG. WARD WARD I
WEBER HOWEVER I. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU A MEMBER LOW. AND NEXT
UP I BELIEVE EVER SOMEONE OR
CHEN WHO I HOPE YOU BRING THAT
THAT SEEM ENTHUSIASM TO YOUR-
PRESENTATION. OF A CHEN I
REMEMBER TO AB SIXTEEN FORTY SIX. MR FLOOR WILL HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU FOR A
LIMITED PERCENT AB EIGHT SIXTEEN
FORTY SIX GOT A MOTION. THANK
YOU GOT A SECOND. RIGHT AS WANT
TO START OFF BY THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORK WITH MY OFFICE ON
CLARIFYING THE ABUNDANCE OF THIS
BILL WE'RE HAPPY EXCEPT THESE
AMENDMENTS- WITHOUT I'M GONNA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WE DO HAVE SOME WITNESS
TESTIMONY- WE HAD PRESIDENT OF
THE CANNABIS BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION- ERIN SILVERSTEIN.
AND BRADDOCK MCLEAN FOR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT IF NEEDED
GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH US ON
A RICH AND- PERRANCE OR SEEN IF
YOU. ARE IN THE ROOM. AND WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
DOESN'T PERSON JUST GETTING MR
SILVERSTEIN IF YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR CAN
LOOK FOR ERIN SILVERSTEIN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION. FOR TESTIMONY
PRIMARY WITNESS TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. MR SILVERSTEIN IF YOU
ARE ON THE LINE WOULD YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME SO
YOU CAN BE IDENTIFIED. JUST A
MOMENT HERE.
THIS RESOURCE TEAM MIGHT HAVE
THOUGHT THE MR CHAN DID SUCH A
GOOD JOB PRESENTING THE BILL
THAT NO ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY WAS
NECESSARY. OKAY MR STILL
SERVICING THE IS ON THE- LINE IS
NOW OPEN RATES MR. TWO MONTHS.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO- CONSIDER THIS BILL
LOS ANGELES. SUBBAN FROM THE
CANNABIS BEVERAGE. AND WE HAVE
ABOUT SUCH WE'RE SPONSORING AB
SIXTEEN FORTY SIX AND WE
CONSIDER THIS TO BE A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR US AS IT
OPENS UP THE FLEXIBILITY AND
PACKAGING THAT IS A LOT FOR
BEVERAGES- RIGHT NOW WE ARE
LIMITED ONLY TO PICK PACKAGING
FOR THESE BEVERAGES. WHICH OF
THE SCREEN SOME SERIOUS SUPPLY
CONSTRAINTS FOR US- CANCER
GENERALLY THE MOST COMMON FORM
FACTOR. AND CURRENTLY ACTUALLY
RELATE THE- ALMOST LAST THREE
YEARS THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT
CAN SHORTAGES AND IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO COME BY. THIS WAS
REQUIRE VERY VERY LARGE ORDERS
WHILE WE HAVE GLASS PACKAGING
THAT'S ALLOWED IN DIFFERENT
COLORS AT THE MOMENT CAMPUS
BEVERAGES. THAT SOMETHING THAT.
CAN BE VERY HEAVY AND DIFFICULT
TO TRANSPORT ESPECIALLY IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY TODAY. SO
FREEING UP OUR PACKAGING TO
ALLOW FOR PLASTIC AND OTHER
FORMATS. WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
HELP FROM INDUSTRY AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I CAN'T REALLY
IMAGINE THERE ARE MANY
DISADVANTAGES TO. I'M VERY HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF
ANYONE HAS ANY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT TESTIMONY AND
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR ANY ARE
THERE ANY PEOPLE IN OPPOSITE IN
SUPPORT SKEWS ME SB ONE SUPPORT
WANT OUT ON YOUR THURMOND. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RAN MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE PARENT COMPANY OR-BETTER KNOWN AS KHALIFA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NAME IS
MARTIN ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
- HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WANT TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE. ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WANT TO
OPPOSE. IS VERY WELL THOUGHT OUT
BILL. SEEING NONE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
FROM THE LINE OF FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN JUST BEAR WITH
ME HERE. OKAY WE DO HAVE A
COMING FROM NINE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. SHARE A MEMBERS
ONLY SHIP PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE DO
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL- QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR. OKAY NINE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
NAME IS JOHNNY CANNELLA ON
BEHALF OF THE BECAUSE OF THE
UNITED KIND OF A BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION YOU CAN BE A CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. FORTY
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER CUTS MR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT
BACK TO COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THE COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. I DON'T SEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NUMBER JO
YOU ARE TO CLOSE. RESPECT RIVA
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU AFRICAN
HUMAN CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THESE ISSUES. I UNDERSTAND WILL
BE TAKING SOME MOMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE TO CLARIFY THE INTENT
OF THE BILL. AND WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS- I'M HAPPY TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL TODAY AND
RECOMMEND SUPPORT. JUST
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN
HI. BERMAN AYE FLORA. FLOOR AYE
BLOOM. LIMB I BONTA CHEN CAN I
CUNNINGHAM FONG. FONG I GIPSON
SAN GRAYSON I IRWIN WE MCCARTY
MEDINA SALAS SALAS AYE AYES
SMITH SMITH I'D HANG. WARD WARD
HI WEBER HOWEVER I. THAT BILL IS
OUT- WITH TEN VOTES AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU THE
NUMBER CHEN EXCEPT WE HAVE A
SUMMER SMITH WITH AB IT WITHOUT
THAT ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. WE HAVE A
MOTION. MEMBER EVAN- SIMILAR
YEAH SNAG THAT BUTTON. BUT WE
WERE GONNA LEAVE I ALL RIGHT
ALSO TO GET A HOT MIKE MOMENT
YOU NEVER KNOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THAT
THOSE DOING CONTRACTED WORK BE
LICENSED BY THE STATE
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD.
UNLESS THE CODE INCLUDING BOTH
LABOR MATERIALS OF ONE OR MORE
CONTRACTS ON THE PROJECT THE
LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THE CAP FOR MINOR CONTRACTED
WORK HAS NOT BEEN UPDATE FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. IN THAT TIME
BOTH THE RAMPANT INFLATION AND
THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS CREATED AN UNDUE
HARDSHIP FOR MANY SMALL
CONTRACTORS AND HANDYMEN. THE
DAY. TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR WOULD
CHANGE THE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CAP FOR UNLICENSED CONTRACT WORK
THE ONLY TO COST OF LABOR SO
LONG AS A IS NOT. TO LIFE. FOR
THAT REASON I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIVEAU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AND DOT I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE ANY PRIMER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO HAVE PRIMARY
WITNESSES ACTUALLY I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT I PROBABLY WOULDN'T
SUPPORT REMOVE ON A PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION WE HAVE
JEREMY SMITH- JEREMY SMITH
YOU'VE GOT TWO MINUTES. WHEN
YOU'RE READY. WHY IT WAS BRING
IT BACK UP. YEAH SURE IPAD BILLS
YOU WHO ARE THEY YOU MISTER
CHAIR CYCLE HE UP THERE WHERE
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE OKAY I HERE'S
MY FOR- THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WAS
COMMITTEE JR SMITH JOB HAVE OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND- TRADES
COUNCIL- MISSED RUN HER.
YESTERDAY BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
TAKE A COUPLE SECONDS POINT OUT.
THAT YOU'RE SITTING IN A ROOM IN
A BUILDING BUILT BY A UNION
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN OUR
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT- WE'RE
ALL VERY PROUD OF THE- PRODUCT
HERE WILL BE ALL HOPE YOU ARE
ALL TOO AND IT'S WORKING OUT FOR
ALL OF YOU. THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE EIGHTEEN
T. PHONE LINES NOT. THAT THE-
FIRST I WANT TO START- IT IS
THEY WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION WE'VE BEEN OPPOSED
TO BILLS LIKE THIS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND THEY'VE COME
FORWARD- FIRST OF ALL WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES HERE- EVEN. AT A MODEST
FATHER OUR THRESHOLD THERE'S
BEEN OVER FOUR THOUSAND NON
LICENSEE COMPLAINTS THE CSL B.
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY- EVEN WITH OUR STRONG
LICENSING. WE'RE STILL GETTING
COMPLAINTS- AT CSL BE ON
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS DOING
WORK. I WOULD NOTE. THAT I'M IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFTER THE WHOLE
HORRIFIC TUBBS FIRE. THE SEATTLE
BE CONDUCTED A STING OPERATION
NABS SIX PEOPLE POSING AS
CONTRACTORS. SIMILARLY THE BUTTE
CAN DISTRICT ATTORNEY AFTER THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- CAMPFIRE FOUND
FOUR PEOPLE POSING AS
CONTRACTORS CONTRACTORS EVEN IN
SITUATIONS AS- DEVASTATING AN
AWFUL IS THAT- OF WEAKENING OUR
EXISTING LICENSING LEVEL OPEN
THE FLOODGATES WERE OPPOSE WHERE
I'M CONCERNED- OF FRAUD AGAINST
MULTIPLE CONSUMERS. SECONDLY
CONCERT- CONTRACTORS IN
UNDERSTAND THEIR OBLIGATIONS. E.
PART OF HAVING A CONTRACTOR'S
LICENSE IS GOING- THAT YOU NEED
TO HAVE BINDING AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION. THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WHEN YOU GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF CSW LEARN ABOUT THIS
IS TO SAFEGUARD CONSUMERS
WORKERS AND THE PEOPLE POSING AS
CONTRACTORS THEMSELVES- IT'S
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT- ANYONE WHO
IS NOT. COVERED BY WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND DOING WORK ON
YOUR PROPERTY IF THEY ARE
INJURED. YOUR HOMEOWNER'S
INSURANCE TAKES OVER- IN THE
CASE OF A CATASTROPHIC ACCIDENT
RESULTING IN DISABILITY OR DEATH
THE CAP ON A HOMEOWNER'S
INSURANCE. WILL RESULT IN A
HOMEOWNER POTENTIALLY THEIR HOME
OR THEIR LIFE SAVINGS TO PAY FOR
THE MEDICAL CARE- AND OUTCOME OF
THAT OF THAT ACCIDENT PLEASE
WRAP UP MISTER I WILL THANK YOU
I'LL- IN WITH THESE TWO POINTS-
WE DO YOU SEE INSTANCES OF. OF
JOBS IN BROKEN UP INTO PIECES
YOU COULD HAVE- IF SOMEBODY USE
A HANDY MAN TO REQUEST INTO YOUR
REMODEL YOU COULD HAVE ONE
WORKER DOING THE FRAMING ONE
WORKER DOING THE DRY WALL
ANOTHER PERSON TO BE SENT TO THE
FINISHING. AND THE LAST DAY
SOMEONE DIFFERENT AGAIN COULD BE
SENT TO THE PAINTING. ALL UNDER
THE FINAL ARE LIM. ALL LEGAL
UNDER THIS BILL FOR BECOME LAW
AND FINALLY I'LL JUST FINISH
WITH THIS- WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE WORKING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CAL OSHA AT THE
LSE AT THEVISION WORKERS
COMPENSATION. TO INVESTIGATE
CLAIMS OF FRAUD ABUSE OF
WORKERS- EXPLOITATION OF
WORKERS- WE NEED TO ENSURE
BEFORE WE LET MORE PEOPLE BE
CONTRACTORS BY. DOING WITH THIS
LIMIT THAT THERE'S ENOUGH WERE
PEOPLE OUT THERE TO INVESTIGATE
. CLAIMS OF FRAUD AND ABUSE
AGAINST WORKERS FOR THOSE ROOMS
WERE OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. ONE ADELINE.
NEED TO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT CRIMMINS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ABOUT A
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CRIMMINS. LET'S OPEN IT
UP TO THE PHONE LINES ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO A. B. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO INCOME AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
ONE AND ZERO. THE FIRST COMMENT
IS FROM LINE TO FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THIS IS KEITH
DONE WITH THE DISTRICT COUNCIL
IRONWORKERS INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA WE SERVE SHE'D OUR
COMMENTS WITH MISTER SMITH AND
WOOD ASKS FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON
MEASURE THANK YOU. THE NEXT
COMMENT IS FOR BLIND. FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS HASN'T CHANGED DIRECTOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL FLAVORS AND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE NEXT THE NEXT
COMPANIES FROM LINE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN ABOUT BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNT TEAMS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT
COMPANIES FROM FIFTY THREE HERE
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR EDUARDO MARTINEZ WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THE NEXT
COMPANY LINE FIFTY FOUR- THANK
YOU UGH MORNING MR- JOHN DOHERTY
I BE W. LOCAL SIXTEEN SAN
FRANCISCO- WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. ONE EIGHT
SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. THAT THE NEXT KEVIN IS FROM
NINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. I HAVEN'T GOT YET. I'M SORRY
GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GREG
HARTMAN- ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTORS- WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. I WISH.
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS POINT. OKAY THERE ARE NO
MORE COMMENTS AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT
BACK ALL THESE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ALEXANDER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THE BILL. SEEING
NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SIR
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THE CAP
ONLINE UNLICENSED WORK. HAS NOT
BEEN ADJUSTED SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. INFLATION IS
INCREASED BY 74% SINCE THAT TIME
. MEANING THAT THESE HANDY MAN
ATTEMPTING TO OPERATE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO. ON NINETEEN NINETY
BUYING POWER. IT IS THE INTENT
OF THIS LEGISLATION TO ALLOW FOR
SUCH OVER THE THRESHOLD THAT
THIS ISSUE NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
. IF IT IS NOT. THEN NEEDS TO BE
STATED POLICY. IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS THIS BILL HAS BEEN TRIED A
NUMBER OF TIMES IN DIFFERENT
WAYS SOME ASKING TO DOUBLE THE
THRESHOLD OTHER SHOT TO TIE IT
TO THE CPI. REGARDLESS OF THE
METHOD TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THE DIX DISCLOSURE FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND FROM GROUPS
OPPOSING THIS BILL HAS BEEN THE
SAME. EVERYONE ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THIS ISSUE EXIST. TECHNOLOGY
THAT IT WILL AFFECT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
AND THEN THEY REFUSED TO ACT- TO
SOMEONE Væ INVENTED CONCERNED
THAT ADDRESSES THAT WILL
INCREASE FRAUD. BUT THE- BUT
THAT WE HAVE EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM I WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR
INPUT ON THIS ISSUE. I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO AMEND THIS BILL IN A
WAY THAT BENEFITS ALL PARTIES
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS WHO
PERFORM THIS TYPE OF WORK.
INDIVIDUALS THAT DON'T HAVE A
VOICE IN SACRAMENTO. SO I ASK
AGAIN. THAT IF WE HAVE A
THRESHOLD FOR UNLICENSED
CONTRACTING WORK HOW CAN WE
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. AS A RETIRED
CONTRACTOR IT'S NOT THE ELEVATOR
OPERATOR THE REMODEL THE LUMBER
ALONE IS GOING TO COST MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS THE DRYWALL
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. THAT IS
NOT THE FRAUD THAT WE'RE AFTER
I'M TRYING TO BE THE VOICE FOR
THE LITTLE MAN. AT THAT TIME A
RETREAT REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH.
WHAT WHILE I UNDERSTAND IN AND
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE. YOUR
INTENT I'M CONCERNED THAT THIS
BILL WOULDPUT HOMEOWNERS AT
GREATER FINANCIAL RISK BY
ALLOWING UNLICENSED INDIVIDUALS.
TO PERFORM CONSTRUCTION WORK AND
OTHER HOME IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
WHEN LABOR COSTS FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR LESS. BUT THERE IS NO
LIMIT ON THE COST OF MATERIALS.
THE BILL ALSO RECEIVED LATE
OPPOSITION LAST WEEK WHICH RAISE
A NUMBER OF POLICY CONCERNS THAT
WARRANT ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION. CONSEQUENTLY I AM
UNABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY- MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN NO BERMAN
NO FLORA. FLOOR HI BLOOM. BLOOM
NO BONTA. CAN CAN I CUNNINGHAM
FONG. FONG I GIPSON. GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON NOW IRWIN LEAN.
LINO MCCARTY MEDINA SALAS SMITH. SMITH I THINK WARD FOR NOW
WEBER WEBER NOW. OTHER VOTERS
FORTY SEVEN WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- THANK YOU
SUMMER SMITH I LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL ON CONSENT
LATER TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. SO WITH THAT I
SEE DOCTOR ARAMBULA. READY TO
ROCK AND ROLL I DON'T NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE.
REMEMBER. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS READY WHEN YOU ARE THINK
IT ARAMBULA I WOULD FIRST LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
SUGGESTED AMOUNT IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS
FURTHER I AGREED TO THESE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE OF. ANALYSIS AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY FIVE WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS SAFEGUARD
OPIOID MEDICATIONS AND REDUCE
THE ACT OF PILFERING. A POWERFUL
ON RAMP TO THE NATION'S OPIOID
ADDICTION CRISIS. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE A PHARMACIST TO
PROVIDE A SCHEDULED OR TWO AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IN A LOCKABLE
CONTAINER. PRESCRIPTIONS SUCH AS
MORPHINE OXYCODONE AND RITALIN.
BILL FOR IN THE ACT OF SNEAKING
A SMALL NUMBER OF PILLS HOPING
THAT IT WILL GO UNDETECTED IS
THE LEADING CAUSE OF OUR YOUTH
OPIOID ABUSE HERE IN AMERICA.
THE OUTDATED CHILD RESISTANCE
PRESCRIPTION VIALS CURRENTLY IN
USE HAVE NOT BEEN MODIFIED IN
OVER FIFTY YEARS. WHEN THE
FEDERAL POISON PREVENTION
PACKAGING ACT WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY. THE GOAL BACK
THEN WAS FOR US TO PREVENT
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE
FROM GAINING ACCESS TO ASPIRIN.
TODAY THOSE SAME CHILD LOCKS ARE
USED TO PROTECT MEDICATIONS
WHICH ARE RANGING. FROM COUGH
MEDICINES TO PRESCRIPTION PAIN
MANAGEMENT MEDICATIONS THAT ARE
EIGHTY TIMES STRONGER THAN
MORPHINE. REQUIRING LOCKING
PRESCRIPTION VIALS FOR POWERFUL
NARCOTICS IS A LOW COST WAY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MODERNIZE THE
ANTIQUATED FEDERAL LAWS THAT ARE
PARTIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
CAUSING THIS NATIONWIDE EPIDEMIC
. THERE ARE TWO WITNESSES HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO SIX
FIVE IT WILL BE PATTY VARGAS WHO
IS REPRESENTING THE RECOVERY
ADVOCACY PROJECT. AND SHERRY
DALY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS. THANK YOU DR
ARAMBULA GOOD AUDIBLE CHAIR
MEMBER SHERRY DALY WITH
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND ADDICTION
COUNSELORS MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY WOULD REST AND THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE RECOVERY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I'M HERE TODAY TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE BOTH AS AN EXPERT IN
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
FIELD AND PERSONALLY AS A
PARENT. FROM A CLINICAL
STANDPOINT WALKING AN IN VERY
EFFECTIVE PREVENTION MEASURE
CONCERNING YOUNG ADULTS AND
ADOLESCENTS THIS AGE GROUP IS
MATURE ENOUGH TO CALCULATE RISK
REWARD POSSIBILITIES FOR THE
ACTIONS STEALING TWO OR THREE
PILLS FROM A CONTAINER PERIOD OF
TIME IS FAR LESS LIKELY TO BE
DETECTED THAN AN ENTIRE
CONTAINER OF MEDITATE MEDICATION
SUDDENLY GOING MISSING THEREFORE
EXPERIMENTING WITH HER
PHARMACEUTICALS FROM HOME
MEDICINE CABINET HAS VERY LITTLE
CONSEQUENCE FROM A PARENTAL
PUNISHMENT PERSPECTIVE BUT FROM
A LIFE AND DEATH STANDPOINT
CONSEQUENCES FROM THIS BEHAVIOR
CAN LITERALLY BE DEADLY.
INCLUDED IN OUR LETTER OF
SUPPORT WITH A NEWS REPORT ABOUT
A FAMILY IN INDIANA WHO
EXPERIENCED THE TRAGEDY THAT CAN
OCCUR WHEN THESE POWERFUL
MEDICATIONS ARE SHARED CASUALLY
AT PARTIES AND MIXED WITH
ALCOHOL. HE SAVAGE HAD TO. SONS
NICK JACK WHO LOVE TALKY
PACHELBEL AND LATE NIGHT
HANGOUTS WHEN IT CAME HOME FROM
COLLEGE TO CELEBRATE YOUNGER
BROTHER JACK'S HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION THE TO.ATTEND A
SMALL PARTY WITH FRIENDS WERE
OPIOIDS AND ALCOHOL WERE SHARED.
IN THE MORNING BECKY WENT TO
PICK UP LAUNDRY IN JACK'S ROOM.
AS WE ALL DO WHEN THEY COME HOME
FROM COLLEGE. SHE FOUND HIM
UNRESPONSIVE. UNBELIEVABLY WHILE
SHE WAS ADMINISTERING CPR
PARAMEDICS ARRIVED BUT WENT
TOWARD THE BASEMENT WHERE
ANOTHER CALL FOR ASSISTANCE HAD
BEEN RECEIVED. THAT NIGHT BECKY
LOST TWO OF HER FOUR SONS TO
OPIOID OVERDOSE OVERDOSE. FOR
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE I'VE
EXPERIENCED PILFERING AND MY OWN
HOME. ALTHOUGH I WAS SPARED THE
HORRIFIC TRAGEDY MISS SAVAGE
SYLLABUS WITH TODAY. AS AN
ADVOCATE A FIELD OF ADDICTION
TREATMENT FOR THREE DECADES I
BELIEVE MY CHILDREN HAD SOMEHOW
BECOME IMMUNE TO SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. AFTER ALL I DID ALL
THE RIGHT THINGS I HAD THE TALKS
I GAVE ALL THE PERTINENT
INFORMATION AND I EXCLUDED THEM
FROM ENVIRONMENTS WHERE I
SUSPECTED DRUG AND ALCOHOL.
WOULD BE A- THEY WERE STRAIGHT
EAST MUSICIAN DANCERS. NONE OF
MY- WERE VERY AFFECTED BY THE
DISS. OF A THAT. WHEN MY COLLEGE
AGE HOW RETURNED UNIVERSITY IN
EUROPE. WITH A SIGNIFICANT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER DIAGNOSIS
WAS SADDENED AND CONFUSED HOW
THE STARTED. WHO HAD INFLUENCE
MY CHILD. WHY WOULDN'T CHILD
EVER START USING DRUGS ASKED. IT
WAS NOT UNTIL EIGHTY MONTHS
INTRO MY CHILD BECAUSE- THAT I
ASKED SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
ONE MIGHT TRIAL TOLD ME THAT HER
USE BEGAN IN MY HOME. BILL
LEFTOVER NORCO FROM A SURGERY I
WAS SHOCKED IN IN THIS. MY HEART
SANK I THOUGHT IF I ONLY KNEW.
HOW MUCH PAYMENTS UP COULD I
HAVE SAVED MY CHILD LIFE. AND MY
OWN FAMILIES. HOW MUCH TIME DO
WE LOSE AND HOW MUCH MONEY WAS
LOST PAYING FOR MONTHS OF
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT. ALL
BECAUSE WE DID NOT HAVE AN EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM. IN OUR HOME.
IT'S TOO LATE FOR BECKY AND- OF
PARENTS WHO. DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY DON'T KNOW. WE CAN CHANGE
THAT WITH AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
FIVE I RESPECTFULLY URGE DRIVE
UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I AM
PATTY VARGAS I'M A STATE
ORGANIZER WITH THE RECOVERY.
PROJECT AND ALSO APPEAR PARENT
COACH WITH THE PARTNERSHIP IN
DETECTION. I'M ALSO A MOTHER HER SON TO OPIOID
ADDICTION. AND I HAVE A DAUGHTER
IN RECOVERY NOW. TO BE HONEST I
SELDOM WORRIED ABOUT MY KIDS
PILFERING FROM MY MEDICINE
CABINET MAINLY BECAUSE THERE
WASN'T ANYTHING THERE. BACK THEN
I HAD AN AVERSION TO NARCOTICS
AND I NEVER TOOK ANYTHING
STRONGER THAN ASPIRIN OR
IBUPROFEN. SO IF MY KIDS WANTED
TO EXPERIMENT THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TO GO ELSEWHERE AND THEY DID.
WHEN MY SON WAS ABOUT SEVENTEEN
I LEARNED THAT HE AND SEVERAL OF
HIS FRIENDS HAD BEEN STEALING
PILLS FROM THEIR PARENTS A
LITTLE HERE. A LITTLE THERE
TRADING AND SELLING BACK AND
FORTH. JOEL'S CONTRIBUTION WAS
HIS OWN ATTAR ALL I HAD NO IDEA
IT WAS A HOT TICKET ON THE
ILLICIT MARKET. I DID
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL OF MY
KIDS FROM THE AGE OF TEN AND UP
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF ALCOHOL AND
MARIJUANA I WAS A KID FROM THE
SIXTIES. I NEVER EVEN CONSIDERED
TALKING ABOUT PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATIONS WHY DID THEY USE
THESE DRUGS. BECAUSE IT WAS SO
EASY TO GET PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
GREG EXPERIMENTATION DOESN'T
START WITH A NEEDLE IN THE VEIN
IT STARTS WITH DRUGS THAT ARE IS
EASY TO GET AS OPENING YOUR
MOM'S MEDICINE CABINET. RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT UP 280% OF HEROIN
ADDICTS BEGAN BY USING
PRESCRIPTION. OPIOIDS WHAT IF
THERE WAS A SAFEGUARD IN PLACE
THAT MADE IT HARDER FOR THEM TO
ACCESS WHAT IF THAT YOUNG PERSON
HAD TO DO A REALLY QUICK RISK
REWARD ASSESSMENT. SNEAKING A
PILLAR TO HEAR IN THERE VERSUS
TAKING THE WHOLE BOTTLE. LOCKING
PILL VIALS ARE AN EFFECTIVE
MEANS OF PREVENTING. OPIOID
ADDICTION MAKING THAT SNAP
DECISION A WHOLE LOT EASIER. TWO
OF MY KIDS EVENTUALLY GRADUATED
OTHER DRUGS INCLUDING HEROIN IN
MATH AND WE LOST JOEL IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. HE WAS A POET HE WAS
A MUSICIAN HE WAS FUNNY AND HE-
HE WAS LOCKED OUT. HE WAS ALSO
BROKEN BY AN UNFORGIVING SYSTEM
AND THE DISEASE HE JUST COULDN'T
BEAT. I WISH I HADN'T BEEN SO
COMPLACENT ASSUMING THAT MY IN
LIGHT AND CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
ALCOHOL AND MARIJUANA ACCURATELY
REPRESENTED WHAT WAS REALLY
GOING ON IN THEIR SCHOOL. IF I
HAD I COULD HAVE POSSIBLY SAVE
THE MANY YEARS THAT THEY LOST TO
ADDICTION ULTIMATELY COSTING MY
SON HIS LIFE. IT COULD HAVE
SAVED OUR FAMILY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
TREATMENT LEGAL FEES AND OTHER
RESIDUAL COST NOT TO MENTION THE
TRAUMA OF CHILD LOST AN
OPPORTUNITY TONIGHT. AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY FIVE WILL ENSURE THAT
SCHEDULE TWO DRUGS ARE
ACCESSIBLE ONLY BY THOSE WHO
NEED THEM AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
VARIOUS IMAGE DALY- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO A PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I BELIEVE WE HAVE-
MISSOULA HORN. THE CALVET
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION. NEAR ME
HEY GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
WHEN THE GOAL HORN AND I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN
DRUG STORES AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY FIVE M. FIRST IS WHEN
I RECOGNIZE THE AUTHORS
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE M. WE
SHARE THAT COMMITMENT TO COMBAT
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE AND
THEFT- UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T
THINK AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE
IS THE APPROPRIATE SOLUTION AS
DRAFTED- FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
WE HAVE THREE PRIMARY CONCERNS
THAT I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
TODAY. FIRST AND WHAT MOST
NOTABLY AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE
FIVE RAISES SOME SERIOUS SAFETY
QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO
PATIENTS BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
THEIR MEDICATIONS SOME PATIENTS
MIGHT HAVE DIFFICULTY OPENING A
LOCKABLE VIAL FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS- OR THEY MIGHT FORGET
THEIR PASSCODE AND BE UNABLE TO
RETRIEVE IT WHEN THEY NEED IT
LEAVING THEM WITHOUT ACCESS TO
THE MEDICATION. SECOND THIS BILL
WILL PUT SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
PRESSURE ON PHARMACIES- M.
ALTHOUGH IT DOES REQUIRE
MANUFACTURERS TO REIMBURSE
PHARMACIES FOR THE COSTS OF THE
LOCK WILL BILES PHARMACIES WILL
STILL HAVE TO FRONT LOAD THE
COSTS AND FOLLOW UP WITH
MANUFACTURERS TO RAISE RECEIVE
PAYMENT. PHARMACIES ACTUALLY
INTERACT WITH MANUFACTURERS
DIRECTLY TYPICALLY GO THROUGH
WHOLESALERS SO TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROCESS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SET
UP AN ENTIRE NEW ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM JUST TO RECEIVE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE LOCKABLE
VIALS M. IMPLEMENTING THE SYSTEM
AND CONSTANTLY FOLLOWING UP WITH
MANUFACTURERS WILL PLACE A NEW
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON PHARMACIES
AND DISTRACT FROM PATIENT CARE
AND I THINK AS WE HONOR
PHARMACIES ARE INCREDIBLY BUSY
PLACES- M. DISPENSING
MEDICATIONS AM DOING HIS ASIANS
AND TESTING THIS IS ONE MORE
THING THAT WILL- PUT A KINK IN
THE WORK FLOW. MY THIRD AND
FINAL POINT PATIENTS ACTUALLY
ALREADY HAVE ACCESS TO LOCKABLE
VIALS I AM IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE WHICH
REQUIRES CHAIN PHARMACIES TO
PROMINENTLY DISPLAY AND OFFERED
TO PATIENTS LOCKABLE STORAGE
PRODUCTS INCLUDING LOCKABLE
PRESCRIPTION VIALS M. THE
PATIENTS IF THEY WANT TO USE
THEM THEY THEY ARE ABLE TO DO
IT. THE SLIDE HAS ONLY BEEN IN
EFFECT FOR A BELIEVE THREE YEARS
SO WE THINK IT IS PREMATURE TO
IMPLEMENT A MANDATE WITHOUT
FIRST SEEING IF THE SLOT IS
WORKING AND. SEEING IF IT HAS
BEEN EFFECTIVE IN ACTUALLY CAN
ADDING PRESCRIPTION DRUG- TELL
FRANK. FOR AN ABUSE. M.
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED THE
COMMITTEE AND- WHICH- THEIR-
THAT PHARMACIES MAINTAIN PATIENT
PASSCODES. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THESE DO NOT REMOVE THE BURDEN
ON PHARMACIES. AM I THINK WE
COULD GET TO A PLACE THAT WE
COULD REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. IF
THE LOCKABLE VIALS ARE MADE
VOLUNTARY AND IF THESE-
BURDENSOME ADMINISTRATIVE AND
FINANCIAL REQUIREMENTS ON
PHARMACIES. M. ARE REMOVED I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WE
ABSOLUTELY SHARE. AND A
COMMITMENT TO FINDING EFFECTIVE
PROVEN WAYS TO COMBAT THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC. AND WE DEFINITELY WORK
WITH THAT THE AUTHOR IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO THIS BUT- AT
THIS TIME WE ARE OPPOSED AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WANT TO
OPEN UP TO ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO ADD ON IS A ME TOO. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- MARC FOR GADABAY
HALF OF NATIONAL NONPROFIT
SHATTERPROOF FOR THE CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL. AND WE ARE DRIVE.
THANK YOU. THE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
SUPPORT OPPOSITION SAYING NINE
ONE OVER THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
YOU WANT TO ADD ON. IN EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT. BEING TAKEN AND-
HARD NOT RIPPING ASSIGNED HIM.
FOR MISTER CHAIRMAN NORTH. OKAY
COVETOUS FROM NINE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
FOR A BILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
RESPECTFUL- OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WANT TO BRING IT BACK
TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. OR OUR MOTION-
SECOND. OR MOTIONS ARE SECONDS I
THINK WE'VE GOT A QUESTION SOME
REWARD TWENTY OFFER I HAVEN'T
CONVERSATION WITH ME YESTERDAY-
WELL I HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW THIS MIGHT BE IMPLEMENTED
I'M REALLY ENCOURAGE ONE THAT-
AND PLEASE CLARIFY FOR THE
RECORD THAT THERE IS AN OPT OUT
PROVISION. IN THE EXPLAINED TO
THE PATIENTS AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS A REALLY GOOD- TO- ON
THE ON ON THE FRONT END THAT'S
ALLOWS FOR NOW ABOUT A OF A
PRESHEAF YOUR CONTINUED- ONE
YOUR YOUR YOUR DEEP STUDY ON THE
ISSUE- BECAUSE I THINK IT WILL
MAKE A POSITIVE DIFFERENCE ON
THE WHOLE AND TO YOUR COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH- THE OPPOSITION
WITH SOME STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL
I'LL TRY TO PERFECT THE BILL SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'LL BE
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOT A MOTION. GOTTA SAY.
NEWS OAKLAND DR WEBER. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR-
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FOR IT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT- WE
NEED TO ADDRESS AND WE NEED TO
FIX SOMEONE I THINK ALL OF THE
WITNESSES AS WELL FOR SHARING
YOUR STORIES WITH US. I YOU KNOW
I DEFINITELY WILL BE SUPPORTING
AND I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF JUST
CLARIFYING. SO THE OVERALL COST
- IS IT THE COUPLE DIFFERENT
DOLLARS IN DIFFERENT AREAS IS
THE TOTAL FOR FIFTY FOUR DOLLARS
AND FIFTY CENTS. IS IT TWO
DOLLARS FOR THE VIAL AND THEN
TWO DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS BACK
TO THE PHARMACIST. NO IT'S
CHARACTER A TWO TO. PER LOCKABLE
FILE- THE ANTICIPATION AND HAPPY
TO ADDRESS THE- OPPOSITION. BUT
AS WE KNOW PHARMACIES ARE BUSY
PLACES BUT WE'VE HEARD
ANECDOTALLY IT TAKES ABOUT FIVE
SECONDS. FOR THE PHARMACIST TO
BE ABLE TO PROGRAM IN. THE
LOCKABLE PILL VIAL AND SO. WHILE
WE'RE ON THERE ARE OTHERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ATTRIBUTE THAT
COST I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO FOCUS ON. THE MECHANISM
THE LOCKABLE PILL VIAL ITSELF.
OKAY SO WHEN IT SAYS- I WENT RAN
. RECEIVING THE PHARMACY
CLAMORING FOR THE COST OF THE
LOCKABLE FILE NOT TO EXCEED TWO
DOLLARS PROFILE AND FOR THE
PHARMACY DISPENSING COSTS AND
SERVICES RENDERED NOT TO EXCEED
TO FIFTY. I DON'T THINK IT
CHANGES THE DISPENSING SERVICES
I BELIEVE THE PHARMACIST HAS THE
SAME RESPONSIBILITIES IT'S FIVE
SECONDS ADDED TO THEM PROGRAM
AND LOCKABLE PULLED BY I DON'T
THINK IT'S- ANY DIFFERENT FROM
THEM- ADMINISTERING
PRESCRIPTIONS TODAY. OKAY SAID
THAT WOULD NOT AT TWO FIFTY IS
THAT I THINK THAT'S WHAT IT'S
CURRENTLY IT'S KNOTS TO EXCEED
THAT OKAY- IS THERE ANY. THE WAY
THAT YOU CAN SEE- AT SOME. THE
INCREASE COSTS BEING PASSED TO
THE PATIENT. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO FOCUS ON THE
FACT THAT MANUFACTURERS HAVE
BEEN PROFITING OFF OF THIS
OPIOID CRISIS FOR QUITE A WHILE
HERE. AND FOR US TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE DIRECTING THE COST TO
THE MANUFACTURERS IS THE INTENT
OF THE BILL- HI I BELIEVE WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE PROFIT MARGINS OF
MANY OF THESE LARGE COMPANIES AS
WELL WITHIN THEIR- PROFITS TO BE
ABLE TO ABSORB SOME OF THE COST
OF ADMINISTERING THIS THE NEW
AND IMPROVED WAY. I THINK SINCE
IT'S BEEN FIFTY YEARS SINCE
WE'VE DONE CHILD RESISTANT FOX I
THINK IT'S LONG PAST TIME. FOR
US TO LOOK AT THE MEDIUM IN
INSURANCE THE MOST PROTECTIVE
THAT WE CAN TO HELP TO ENSURE
THAT WHAT OCCURRED HERE IS NOT
GOING TO OCCUR AGAIN. NO I AGREE
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT AS IT
MOVES FOR YOU'RE PROBABLY
LOOKING TO SEE IF THERE'S A WAY
IN WHICH WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
MANUFACTURERS WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO PASS THESE COSTS DOWN TO
PATIENTS BECAUSE PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. ARE ALREADY EXTREMELY
HIGH FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE AND WE
WOULDN'T WANT THOSE THAT NEED IT
TO HAVE THIS AS A BARRIER- I
WOULD ALSO JUST- YOU KNOW
ENCOURAGE YOU TO. CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I DID HAVE DOWN IS THE UP.
FRONT COST BURDEN TO MANY OF THE
PHARMACIES- IT MAY NOT BE THAT
BIG OF A DEAL FOR SOME OF THE
LARGER CHAINS LIKE CVS TO
WALGREENS BUT WE ALWAYS HAVE
LIKE THE SMALLER. YOU KNOW MOM
AND POP PHARMACISTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND- WE WOULDN'T
WANT THIS TO BE TOO MUCH OF A
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON THEM WHERE
THEY'RE UP FRONTING THE MONEY
AND THEN HAVING TO WAIT. THIS
TIME TO GET REIMBURSED BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR- DOING THIS
AND I'M LOOKING FOR TO
SUPPORTING IT. THANK YOU AND I
WILL JUST ADD IF I CAN THAT
CURRENTLY WITH CHILD RESISTANCE
LAW- BILES THE PHARMACIES HAVE
TO FRONT LOAD THAT COST AND
INVENTORY THEM AS WELL AND THEY-
ARE NOT ABLE TO BE REIMBURSED OR
REBATE FOR THEM. THAT THIS
ACTUALLY MAY BE ABLE TO ASSESS
SOME OF OUR PHARMACY SINCE WE'RE
CREATING A WAY IN WHICH- THE-
THAT REBAY. ON AND- WILLING TO
WORK THE OFFICE. BUT JUST WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT AND BRING THAT UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. CNN DOCTOR I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE WE HEARD HERE TODAY
HOW IT WAS SO EASY FOR SO MANY
OF OUR CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE OPIOID
MEDICATIONS AND THAT LOCKABLE
PILL VIALS ARE AN EFFECTIVE
MEANS FOR US TO HELP TO WORK ON
THIS OPIOID EPIDEMIC WITH OUR
CHILDREN I WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT
WHAT'S OCCURRED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND THUS THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL IS EVEN MORE NOW THAN
IT WAS LAST YEAR WHEN I
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED THAT. AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I. THANK YOU DR RANDALL AND
I JUST WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT
YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
MEMORIZED. THANK YOU FOR
CONFIRMING THAT ON THE RECORD.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYBODY WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY. AND I
UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE THIS
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS DO NOT
REMOVE THE BILL'S OPPOSITION-
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
FOR ACCEPTING THEM. AND YOU THIS
IS A VERY RIGHTEOUS ISSUE. IT'S
YOU KNOW POPE OFFERING AS WE'VE
HEARD IS SUCH AN EPIDEMIC AND IN
OUR COMMUNITIES IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE- AND A LOT OF.
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED THAT-
YOU KNOW I THINK ARE LEGITIMATE
AND I KNOW YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO- I. ADDRESS THE
RIGHTEOUS ISSUE. AND MAKE IT AS
AS THE- LEAST ONEROUS AS
POSSIBLE- SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THAT AND WITH
THAT. I'M COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY AND RECOMMENDING
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
JUDICIARY. BERMAN I. BERMAN AYE
FLORA. LARA NOT VOTING BLOOM.
WHY AM I BONTA. TEN I'M NOT
VOTING CUNNINGHAM FONG. I'M NOT
VOTING GIPSON. GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE IRWIN ME MAY I MCCARTY
MEDINA SALAS SALAS I SMITH. BUT
NOT VOTING TANK. WARD. WEBER
HOWEVER I. THANK YOU MISTER WILL
BE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND SO
WE ARE NOW GOING TO FLIP BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE I BELIEVE I HOPE
WE'VE GOT ASHLYNN SALZBURG ON
THE LINE WANT TO APOLOGIZE- TO
MISS SALSBERG WE'VE GOT SOME
WRONG CALLING- IN THAT WENT OUT
YOU EARLIER THIS MORNING- BEFORE
THIS MORNING AND BY WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT- ABSENT IT'S ENOUGH.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF DR
WEBER'S BILL AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
TWO WHICH IS CURRENTLY- ON- SO
TEST MORE WILL BE VERY HELPFUL
FOR US- SO EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY ASH SALZBURG
FOR TWO MINUTES OF- TESTIMONY
AND OF AB. SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO.
HEY MICHELLE SERGEI LINE IS OPEN. YOU CAN HEAR CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN THANK YOU- YEAH OKAY
VETERANS- SHE GOOD MORNING MY IS
I HOPE ALL HERTZBERG EILEEN AND
REPLY IN LAS ANGELES AND I AM
ALSO COLLIDE WHICH I WOULD DIE
WITH WHEN I WAS EIGHT ALTER
CLIENTS THE NEW TWENTY THREE
FEET IN NON COM CALLED ID. NEEDS
MANY DOWN THE ONES THAT WE ARE
AND IMMEDIATE NEED TO RELIEVE
MYSELF AND USE THE RESTROOM
WHICH IS WHY HERE TODAY- URGE
YOU TO PASS A ONE SIX THIRTY
JAIL KNOWN THE REST MAX ACT I
THINK HUNTING HERE LEAVING MY- I
THANK KNOW WHEN- ACTUAL COME IN
HAVING AN- KNOW REST BILL. THIS
WILL HELP EASE MY FEARS AND GIVE
ME BACK MY LIFE. WITH ITS ACT I
WILL NO LONGER BE WORKING ACCESS
TO. WHEN IT NEEDED. WELL I HAD
NO. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT Q.
EXPERIENCE. THAT REALLY BROUGHT
A FOR ME I THINK SHE NEEDS FOR.
FIRST HE GALOPIN BEGINNING THE
PANDEMIC.
AND ACTIVISTS SALARY I NEED
FRANK URGED IN THE BACK THERE
AND- CAMPAÑA I WOULD NOT ALLOWED
IN THE- YOU MAY NOT AND I WENT
TO AN INJURY CONVENIENCE.
HOWEVER THE EMPLOYEE FOR TO
ALLOW ME MISTER. EVEN AFTER
EXPLAINING MY CONDITION ENSURING
MY CURRENT THE CLIENTS CARD AS A
RESULT I'M THRILLED MYSELF
CAREFULLY I THINK THERE AND I
HAD NO CHANGE OF CLOTHES SO WE
HAD TO GO HOME AND I COULD NOT
GET TO SEE MY GRANDFATHER. YOU
WANT TO GO I WAS WALKING HOME
AFTER THOUGHT IN THE CAR WITH
ALL THE TIME I THOUGHT. NEED YOU
CAN GO BACK. I THOUGHT THAT IN
YOUR PIPE START INCHER THE MICRO
BE QUITE CAR. AND TOLD ME I NOT
YOU THE RESTROOM I CROSS THE
THREE AND RAN FIFTEEN THE HIGH.
THERE I WAS MET WITH THINK WE'RE
- AFTER PUT. MY AND IT. TO THEM
I THINK IT. LUCKILY THE L. I CAN
HERE. ENABLE ME USE THAT THE
FILM REJECT CABINET. HE COULD
NOT HAVE. NO ONE TRYING THREE
PLACES IN THE RIGHT. I WOULD SO
NERVOUS HAVING ACCIDENT AND I
WONDER WHY WOULD HAPPEN IF THE
LACK WEEK DID NOT GIVE ME ACCESS
. DETECTION HAVE A LOOK AND NO
ME SOMETHING IS BANK I THANK ON
BEHALF. ALL I BE PEEPING EFFECT
PERHAPS YOUNG BACKWARDS I FOR
YOU IN THE STRONGEST. PLEASE
SPELL I KNOW SO MANY KIDS LIKE
ME BRING EACH THIRTY. FOR FEAR
THAT THE CHAMBER CAN. NAMES THAT
I.
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSELIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WONDER FOR TET WONDERFUL
TESTIMONY AND ADVOCACY I ASSURE
YOU I WASN'T DOING THAT AT
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR BRAVERY FOR SHARING
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH-
WITH WITH US WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND PUTTING OUT A VOICE TO
SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF YOUR
PEERS ARE ARE ALSO GOING THROUGH
SOME REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
STICKING WITH US. AND TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
TWO WE WILL CONTINUE THE VOTE ON
THAT AT THE END OF OUR HEARING
WHICH SHOULD HOPEFULLY BE IN IN
NOT TOO LONG ABOUT APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING IN TO TESTIFY. SO WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON IT TOO
I BELIEVE SO MEMBER HOLDEN'S
BILL ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE.
WARNING MORNING. THE JURY
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO DAY 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE BILL THAT SEEKS TO
UPDATE OUR OUT OF DATE AND
DEEPLY INSUFFICIENT THAT
MICROCHIPPING AND PAT THE FLAWS
. AMBER'S I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE HIGH
PROFILE INSTANCES OF THAT STUFF.
INCLUDING SOME PET OWNERS BEING
ROBBED AT GUNPOINT. NO DOUBT
THERE HAVE BEEN CONSTITUENTS IN
OUR OWN COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
SUFFERED FROM THE DRAMATIC LOSS
OF A PET. BOB A LOSS OF A PET BY
BAD ACTORS LIKE THIEVES. HOWEVER
IN MANY US CONSTITUENCIES ONE
INDIVIDUAL WITH CONSTITUENT A
CURATIVE LENI WAS JOINING US AS
A WITNESS TODAY SUFFERED THE
THEFT OF HER PET DOG AT THE
HANDS OF THE VERY RESCUE GROUP
WHICH SOLD HER THE DOG. AND
DESPITE THE OBVIOUS OWNERSHIP HE
RETAIN NO EXPLICIT LEGAL RIGHTS
TO HER DOG BECAUSE THE MICROCHIP
WAS REGISTERED WITH THE RESCUE
GROUP. AS THE PRIMARY CONTACT.
IT IS VITAL THAT WE PROTECT OUR
PETS AND CONSUMERS BY ENACTING
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE.
THIS BILL UPDATES PET ADOPTION
AND MICROCHIPS STANDARDS BY
REQUIRING THAT ALL SHELTERS AND
RESCUE GROUPS PROVIDE TO ADOPT.
A TO BRIDE TO ADOPTERS THE
PROPER RESOURCES ACCESS POINTS
AND ASSISTANCE WERE UPDATING THE
PRIMARY CONTACT REGISTERED. TO
THE MICROCHIP IN PLACE IN THE
PAST. WITH THE BILL THAT'S TO BE
ADOPTED. THIS IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT EVERY NEWLY
ADOPTED COULD BE MICROCHIPPED
WITH INFORMATION REFLECTIVE OF
THEIR TRUE OWNER RATHER THAN THE
INFORMATION. OF THE SHELTER OR
RESCUE GROUP WHICH MERELY HELD
THEM UNTIL THEY FOUND THEIR HOME
. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL WILL
HEIGHTEN STANDARDS OF DUE
DILIGENCE FOR PET ADOPTION. ALL
SHELTERS AND RESCUE GROUPS WILL
BE REQUIRED TO MEET THE
STANDARDS OF ALREADY DILIGENT
AND GOOD ACTING ORGANIZATIONS BY
RELEASING PETS TO OWNERS. WITH
THE MOST MEANINGFUL PROOF OF
OWNERSHIP AS OPPOSED TO SIMPLY
MICROCHIP REGISTRATION UNTIL
OWNERS ONLY SO LONG AS THEY HAVE
NO DOCUMENTED HISTORY OF PET
MISTREATMENT. THIS IN EFFECT
WILL PREVENT BAD ACTORS FROM
RECLAIMING PATHS TO THE
DETRIMENT OF WAR AND LOSS OF THE
PETS TRUE OWNER. AND IT WILL
PREVENT PET ABUSERS FROM
ACCESSING ACCESSING LOW LOST
PETS WHOSE FAMILIES ARE STILL
SEARCHING FOR. LASTLY AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY THREE WILL
INCLUSIVELY CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF AT THE- END GIVE
OWNERS GREATER REDRESS TO
REUNITE WITH THEIR PET. AND
INSTANCES OF TRADITIONAL CUT
THAT OFF AND IMPROPER
RECLAMATION. BY SHELTERS AND
RESCUE GROUPS. MY OFFICE SAYS
CONVENE MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS ON THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO UNDERSCORE THAT I'M COMMITTED
TO ADDRESSING AND ELIMINATING
ANY POTENTIAL NEGATIVE IMPACTS
ON LOCAL SHELTERS. AND RESCUE
GROUPS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. WITH ME TODAY ON THE
LINE TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE OUR-
YOU'RE A TO LEANING. ON MY
CONSTITUENT FROM PASADENA RURAL
HOMES FORMER POLICE CHIEF ANIMAL
CONTROL OFFICER- ASSISTANT. FOR
THE L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
ANIMAL CONTROL WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK YOU
MR HOLDEN- AND- MISCELLANY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COME PRESENT. ARE
THEY ON A ON THE PHONE. YES I'M
READY PERFECT. MARIANELA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT IS AN HONOR
SPEAKING TODAY MY NAME'S T. R.
TWENTY ACTUALLY FOR THE FAMILY
MEMBER WHO SUPPORT FOR EVEN.
SEVENTY THREE. THE DOGS AND CATS
. IT MAY BE ARE THE LAST TODAY
POP TO GET A BACK TO THE RIGHT
YOU HAVE BOUGHT FROM BUT THAT MY
DOG GETTING OUT ONE TIME I WAS A
BIT. IF THE PART MY FAMILY I TO
DO MY PART TO REDUCE EUTHANASIA
BY GETTING DOG FROM SHELTER.
READERS MEETINGS NEARLY SIXTY
THAT SOUND RIGHT BASS LOCAL REP
I'M A ONE OLD AT THE NEW MADERA
STATUS DE. YOUR SEATS ARE
COUNTRY WHAT ABOUT. TO AND MY- I
WAS RESPONSIBLE OWNER ACTION IS
TRAINS SO EXERCISE MY OUR DAILY. NUMBER MY FOR ALMOST FORTY.
AND DO NO FAULT OF OWN MIND. ARE
ABLE GET MY- FURSTENBERG'S ABOUT
MAKE YOUR CALL RESCUE. I THEM
THAT A COUPLE HOURS. HELLO
BECAUSE THE VERY PUBLIC. OVER SO
. MONTHS IN THE OLD. I HAD NO
CLUE. ABOUT SHE TWO YEARS LATER
WHEN I'M GOING TO BUY THE BOOK
CARE. STILL ALIVE. AND WITH THE
FACT THE RESCUE PURCHASE FROM
HIDDEN HER. ENTIRE TIME. THREE
HUNDRED YEARS. PRESS I CURRENTLY
GO. TO RETURN OF MY TO. ALL
THREE PARTIES.
THE COMPANY OF WHO ACTUALLY ON
THE DOCK. WHEN CARS REPOSSESSED
THERE'S KNOWS THAT OPPORTUNITY
REMAINS. ON A CHILD TAKEN FROM
THE HOME THERE'S A LEGAL PROCESS
FOR THE PARENT. OR GUARDIAN TO
BE HEARD EDUCATION OR TO REGAIN
CUSTODY. AND LIBERALS BEEN
CAPTIVATING PETS WHO ARE LAS
INFLECTED ABUSER DANGERS IS THAT
LEGAL DIRECTION BEFORE COMING.
IN AND- SHOULD NOT. AND FOR.
RESCUE THREE AND THAT APOLLO
OFFICIAL WOULD NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO. THEIR USER YOU THE
LEAD. HAS THE TRUST PUBLIC GET.
SEXUAL MAKING OUR CLEAR BY REPLY
THE REAL THE DOG CAT OF MY- CAL
. THE AND AGONY GO THROUGH THEY
CAN'T WORK THERE AND- DO BAD ACT
. MOST PROPERTY COMES WITH THE
BUT NOW OUR DOG OR CATS YOU BOTH
ARE FINISHED THE MOTION
INVESTMENT OF IT IS A- MANY
POINT. CLAIM OWNERSHIP THEM
SIMPLE JOHN J. AND ARE.
STANDARDS ABOUT ANY READER
WHAT'S WHAT. I'M SPEAKING TO YOU
TODAY BECAUSE MY PEOPLE DON'T
THE MEANS THE KERR. OF BY FOR
THEIR CUTS TO TUITION BUT MY-
FOR THE SAKE OF THE LIGHT ME AND
FOR. ANIMAL TURN MEMBERS I
ARGUED. VOTE YES ON THE BEACH-
SEVENTY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH IN CONGRATS
FITTING FOUR MINUTES OF TESTING
TO DO MAN- WHO IS- I THEY'RE
GOING TO DO. IN THIS ABOARD.
ZEROED IN AB IS THAT. THERE WAS
.  HISTORY- LET'S SEE THAT'S A
HOME PERFECT MISS HOLMES IF YOU
ON THE LINE. CONTINUE PATTERSON
I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW SIR WE
CAN'T THANKS. OKAY GOOD MORNING
THIS REGIONAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IF YOU CURRENTLY SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. WHEN I RETIRED AS A CHIEF
OF POLICE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
I STARTED A SECOND CAREER IN
ANIMAL CONTROL FOR TWENTY YEARS
I WORKED FOR TWO LARGE COUNTY
ANIMAL CONTROL AGENCIES. I'M
ALSO A LICENSED CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY. HAS AN ATTORNEY I MUST
GIVE THE DISCLAIMER BUT I AM NOT
REPRESENTING OR SPEAKING FOR THE
GOVERNMENT FOR ANIMAL CONTROL
AGENCY. BUT I AM SPEAKING WITH
ALL THE KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE
TO COME FROM DECADES OF DEALING
WITH MICROCHIPPING AND THEFT.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY THREE AS A POLICE
OFFICER INDETERMINABLE
CONTROLLER AND WITNESSED
COUNTLESS CASE PEOPLE STOLE
POLITE THE LONER. THEY COULD NOT
BE PROSECUTED BECAUSE OUR
INITIAL CONSTRUCTION BICYCLE
ALONG. WITH LEGAL. WELL FIXTURES
THAT. WE SAW ME I OF MIKE.
NINETY TWO THAT CAN GET LOS IN
THE WAR WAY TO GET. THAT YOU GET
YOUR FAMILY MEMBER. SOME OF THE
LAWSUIT MANDATE MICROCHIP. BUT
WE BETRAY THAT PROMISE AND TRUST
AND WE DON'T CHECK FROM. DON'T
RESEARCH. WHICH IS STILL BOTHER
ME ANY EFFORT TO PUMP THE ACT
OWNER. ON THE CHIPS BECAUSE WE
WANT THE ANIMAL OUT OF OUR
SHELTER. NO MATTER WHERE IT GOES
. ONLY USE THAT MAINTAIN A ON
CUTS WHAT WILL ON THE APPROACH
WHEN PATRICK TOPIC MORE PUSH PER
TITLE SHOULD FULL WITH AN OWNER
FAILED TO CARE AN ANIMAL LONG
FOR NOT TO RESCUE SHOULD AND CAN
SEIZE. BUT THAT SHELTERS AND TO
SHIPPING. CRIED OWNERSHIP OF THE
APPROACH. OF ALL PARTIES TO DO
OF THE CHIU IN FROM. THIS BILL
HELPS AVOID. CREATED BY. THIRD
PARTY IN BAD ACTOR CHIP WHERE.
THREE GAUGED IN HER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE LONG IN ORDER SHALL CALL
FOR. REPUTABLE SHELTERS ALREADY
HOLD THE TWENTY. WHEN THE CHIPS
FOUND. THIS BILL IS A VITAL SO
IN SOME CREATE A GREATER. FOR
SHALL AND- CORRECT AGAIN SHAPE
WHEN IT COMES MICROCHIP AND
REQUIRE CUTS. DESPITE WHAT ALSO
. THIS BILL TRULY SERVICEABLE
INTERESTS A PATH. THEIR OWNERS
SHELTERS IN THE ALL. PLEASE HOLD
WHILE I ON THE TWENTY SOME
TWENTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND NOW WANT TO OPEN
FOR ANY. WITH IN OP- I DO THINK
WE HAVE ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM
BUT IF THERE PRIME WITNESSES AN
OPPOSITE ON THE- LINE- PLEASE.
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND- GOSH.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES THANK
YOU. CORRECT HARPER AND THE CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
HUNDREDS OF NONPROFIT AND
MUNICIPAL ANIMAL SHELTERS AND
ANIMAL CONTROL AGENCIES AROUND
STATE ORGANIZATION IS OPPOSED TO
THIS LEGISLATION UNLESS AMENDED
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT WOULD
HAVE A CATASTROPHIC IMPACT ON
THEIR OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA'S
SHELTERS. WHAT WE DO AGREE THAT
SHELTERS AND RESCUES SHOULD NOT
BE LISTED AS THE OWNER ON
MICROCHIPS ONCE CUT FOR A-
YOU'RE SHOWING OPPOSE TO
LIMITING DETERMINE OF OWNERSHIP
THE NAME LISTED ON THE MARKET.
MICROCHIP FOR SIMPLY ONE OF MANY
MEANS THAT I DON'T FOR PAT AND
OUR ANIMALS PROFESSIONALS
NAVIGATE THAT YOU EACH AND EVERY
DAY WORKING DILIGENTLY TO RETURN
TO THEIR RIGHTFUL OWNERS
LIMITING. TO THE MICROCHIP ONLY
WITHIN THE CAPABILITY OF ID TAG
LICENSES AND YEARS OF VETERINARY
RECORDS BUT MANY PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO PROVIDE QUALITY CLEANING
THEIR ANIMAL ONE SHOULD ALSO BE
MINDFUL THAT IT IS POSSIBLE TO
FEEL AN ANIMAL AND IMMEDIATELY
HAVE IT SHIPPED WITH A NEW PARTY
INFORMATION. ADDITIONALLY WITH
NO ALPHA ON THIS LEGISLATION
ANIMALS WOULD NEED TO BE HELD
INDEFINITELY ANY LEGISLATION
THAT IMPACT THE LENGTH OF TIME A
SHELTER IS REQUIRED TO CARE FOR
AN ANIMAL MUST NOT POWER AS A
RESULT IN AN UNFUNDED. MANDATE
UNIFICATION CAN BECOME. AND I
DON'T. TECH I CONTINUE OF ALL.
THERE IS NO. THAT THE- NEEDS TO
DICTATE REUNIFICATION EFFORT
OTHERS. ARE ALREADY UP NOW THE
IT IS. FOUR HUNDRED OF THOUSANDS
OF ANNA EACH. WE'RE HOPEFUL WORK
WITH THE I. OFF FUNDING. THE
BILL AT THIS TIME RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NOSE UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A WE HAVE
ONE A THIS IN A WIN IS AN
OPPOSITE MS. YEAH GOOD MORNING
SHERRY MAY IS JOY TOP AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS PERCENT HUMANE SOCIETY
. I'D LIKE TO START BY. THE
AUTHOR IN HIS FOR TACKLE THIS
COMP IS. THERE IS A WAY THING WE
HOLD AGREE UPON THAT IS IT IS
NOT AND- WITH BEST PRACTICES TO
ALLOW FOR RESCUE GROUPS OR
SHELTERS. TO REMAIN THE PRIMARY
CONTACT ON A MICROCHIP ONCE
UNLAWFUL ADOPTION IS TAKING
PLACE. THAT IS REALLY THE HEART
OF THIS ISSUE AND WHAT ALLOW THE
RESCUE GROUP INVOLVED IN
MISCELLANEOUS CASE TO STILL HER
DOG AND PRESENT TO THE COURT
THEMSELVES AND THE RIGHTFUL
OWNER. WHERE WE DIVERGE IS THE
PROVISION THAT ALLOWS- ANIMALS
ONLY TO BE RECLAIMED IF THEY
HAVE UP TO DATE MICROCHIPS. WELL
A USEFUL TOOL MICROCHIPPING IS
AN IMPERFECT TECHNOLOGY. UNTIL
FAIRLY RECENTLY SAN DIEGO HUMANE
ERRONEOUSLY ASSUMES THAT BECAUSE
WE PROVIDED INFORMATION TO NEW
PET OWNERS ON HOW TO REGISTER
THEMSELVES ON THE CHIP THAT IT
WAS HAPPENING. IT WAS ONLY WHEN
IMPLEMENTING THE PROVISIONS OF
THE MANDATORY MICROCHIP BILL
THAT PASSED TWO YEARS AGO THAT
WE REALIZE MANY DOCTORS NEVER
FOLLOWED THROUGH. WELL WE NOW
HAVE AN AUTOMATED PUSH FROM ARE
SHELTERING SOFTWARE MICROCHIP
COMPANY WE CONTRACT WHEN. THERE
COULD BE THOUSANDS OF LAWFUL
ADOPTIONS INVALIDATED BY THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE THE CHIPS
WERE NEVER UPDATED ARE
REGISTERED. FURTHER THERE ARE
DOZENS OF MICROCHIP aPANIES
AND THEY DO NOT ALWAYS SHARE
INFORMATION AMONG THEMSELVES OR
USE A SINGLE PLATFORM TO OF THE
ORDER INFORMATION WHEN WHICH
EMIT TRANSFERS OF OWNERSHIP TAKE
PLACE. SHELTERS NAVIGATE THESE
CHALLENGES BY UTILIZING MORE
THAN ONE SOURCE OF OWNERSHIP
DOCUMENTATION. THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF SHELTERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WERE EFFECTIVELY
NAVIGATING THE PROCESS OF
RETURNING PETS TO THEIR RIGHTFUL
OWNERS AND ARE EXERCISING THEIR
DUE DILIGENCE IN DOING SO. SAN
DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY'S RECLAIM
RATE FOR DOGS FOUR TIMES GREATER
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE AND
EIGHT TIMES GREATER FOR CAPS.
IT'S OUR ABILITY TO USE THAT-
MANY TOOLS OF OWNER
IDENTIFICATION SUCH AS COLLARS
WITH TAGS VACCINATION HISTORY
VETERINARY RECORDS AND OTHER
DOCUMENTATION TO PROVE OWNERSHIP
THAT ALLOWS SAN DIEGO HUMANE.
SOCIETY TO BE SO SUCCESSFUL WITH
A PROGRAMS. WE HAVE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS THE OTHER OFFICE THAT
FILL OUT A- AND CAN. WALKING TO
ALLOW SOME DOING IN THE REAR.
EFFORTS TO USE THEIR EXPERT AND
JUDGE. IN THE BASS AND OF LOS
PETS IN THE- WE OUR HIS. OPEN TO
ENGAGE AND WE WILL FORWARD TO.
CHANGES THAT WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION UNTIL THEN
UNFORTUNATELY WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FILLS OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IF YOU
WANT TO ADD ON IS A ME TOO IN
THE HEARING ROOM RIGHT NOW.
SEEING NONE. LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANY. GONNA ADD
ON ME TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS TO DISPLAY MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WANT
TO BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
GEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND SOME HOME
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRING THIS
LEGISLATION OVER TO- THE YEAR-
COMMITTEE. ON I THINK THIS IS A
FOR LEGISLATION AS IT'S GOING TO
PREVENT SOME NEFARIOUS ISSUES
HAPPEN IN TERMS OF SHELTERS
PREMATURE RULING- BUT IN GOAL OF
THE ANIMAL CAT OR DOG OR EVEN IN
SOME CASES SELLING- THE- CAT OR
DOG. SO MY QUESTION IS MOSTLY IN
TECHNICAL IN TERMS OF ITS
IMPLEMENTATION- IN THE EVENT.
THAT A CAT OR DOG OR ANIMALS
BROUGHT TO THE SHELTER AND IT
DOES HAVE A CHIP. BUT WHAT IS
THE TIME FRAME. OF HOW LONG THE
SHELTERS WILL BE HOLDING ON. TO
THE CATID ALREADY ANIMAL. BEFORE
IN THE EVENT THAT- THE ORIGINAL
OWNER CANNOT BE FOUND. AND THAT
IT CAN BE ADOPTED BY A NEW OWNER
. BRIGITTE THAT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
CURRENT STATUTORY TIME FRAMES-
TIME WE DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC
AMOUNT OF TIME RIGHT TO SHARE
WITH YOU AT THIS MOMENT BUT IT'S
ALREADY SET IN STATUTE AND THIS
BILL DOES NOT ALTER THE- I THINK
I'VE ALSO HEARD SOME MISLEADING
INFORMATION JUST ONE CLARIFIED
THAT DIED. IN THE EVENT THAT-
ANIMALS FOUND WITH A MICROCHIP.
THAT THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE AN
CHANGE IN TERMS OF. IF THE
ORIGINAL OWNERS NOT FOUND THAT
THIS WOULD EXPEDITE THE ANIMAL
FROM- IN EUTHANIZED OR OR LET GO
IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT I'M I'M
VERY CONFIDENT THAT ISNOT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL. YOU'RE
YOU'RE RIGHT IT IS NOT INTENT OF
THE BILL- AND I MIGHT JUST ALSO
SAY IT'S NOT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL. TO DO AWAY WITH ANY
CURRENT PRACTICES THAT. RIGHT
ORGANIZATIONS AGENCIES HUMANE
SOCIETIES ARE USING AND- SEEING
GOOD RESULTS BY. WE'RE SORT OF
WALKING INTO AN AREA WHERE
CLEARLY THERE IS A DEFICIENCY.
WE'RE TRYING TO TIGHTEN THAT
PIECE- AND SO WHERE. THE CURRENT
OPPOSITION AS INDICATED THEIR
CONCERNS WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM AND WILL COME UP WITH
THE LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO A
GOOD THING NOT ELIMINATE WHAT
ARE ALREADY SUCCESSFUL
TECHNIQUES THAT ARE BEING USED.
TO REUNITE FAMILIES WITH THEIR
LOSS. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL AND-
I KNOW THAT TO YOUR REPUTATION
SECOND TO NONE AND- YOU CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION I
LOOK FORWARD TO A SUPPORT YOUR
BILL AT THIS TIME. BECAUSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE SHORT. THANK
AT ONE APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT IS GOING
TO BE POSITIVE AND I NEED TO
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
THE SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY I
KNOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH MULTIPLE CHAPTERS OF THE
MEANS OF THE MID SIZE ACROSS THE
STATE- AND THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK THEM AS WELL SO TODAY I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL- BUT TO
ANY EXTENT THAT WE CAN WORK ON
OPTIONS FOR- DEMONSTRATING
OWNERSHIP. AND ALSO WITH SPECIAL
ATTENTION TO ON HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BONDED
WITH THEIR PETS I THINK WOULD BE
HELPFUL AS THIS APPROACH IS THE
FLOOR THANK YOU APPRECIATE. YOU
MISTER WARD BONTA AT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AYE
AYE MY DOG LEGO LOS ALSO THINKS
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I
WE IN OUR DISTRICT ACTUALLY HAVE
IN MY CITY IN PARTICULAR RELY
SIGNIFICANTLY ON AT NONPROFIT
RESCUE SHELTER TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THAT
ENSURE THAT THERE WON'T BE ANY
ADDITIONAL BURDEN PLACED ON ON
SHELTERS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
AND IT'S ALREADY A PART OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE- THAT WE CONTINUE
TO UNDER INVEST IN- AS A SOCIETY
AND TO AND HOPING THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEIR-
OPPOSITION TO ENSURE THAT THERE
ISN'T ANY ADDITIONAL BURDEN THAT
WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE.
ALL OPPORTUNITIES TO IDENTIFY
OWNERSHIP- TO ENSURE RAINY
REUNIFICATION WHEN THEY NEED NOT
ONLY IN THE CHIP AND KNOW THAT
WE WILL GET THERE I WITH THIS
AND FOR THAT REASON THOSE
REASONS I WILL BE VOTING YES ON
THIS. NAME IS BONTA ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR MOTIONS OR SECONDS. GOT A
MOTION GOT A SECOND- HOLDEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- YES
RESEARCHER AND COMMITTEE I FIRST
OF ALL I JUST APPRECIATE- THE
IMPORTANCE OF. THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS AND WE WILL ADDRESS
THEM I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
SORT OF HIT HOME VERY QUICKLY
YESTERDAY AS I WAS AT THE
AIRPORT IN BURBANK COMING UP
HERE. THE START THIS WEEK AND I
GOT A PANIC CALL FROM MY WIFE
AND SHE SAYS THAT THE BACK GATE
WAS OPEN AND- OUR DOG KOBE WAS
GONE. AND SHE WAS VERY VERY
UPSET. AND THEN OF COURSE I'M-
THEN OKAY WILL DRIVE AROUND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THE FIRST THING
THAT CAME INTO OUR MIND WAS DO
WE GET A CHIP. AND WE DID BURKE
THERE WE REGISTER THE CHIP YOU
KNOW SO THERE'S ALL THESE THINGS
THAT START RUNNING THROUGH YOUR
MIND AFTER THE FACT- IT IS TO
SAY- HE WAS ON THE NEIGHBOR'S
PORCH. A CHASING AFTER SOMETHING
SO IT WORKED OUT BUT THERE WAS
THAT PERIOD OF TIME. WHERE
YOU'RE NOT QUITE SURE JUST WHAT
HAPPENED. THE BACK GATES UNLOCK
WE JUST REAL RECENTLY DETERMINED
IT WAS PROBABLY FROM THE
GARDENERS THE DAY BEFORE NEVER
CLOSED IT. AND THERE YOU HAVE IT
SO- WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT FIRST
OF ALL THESE OR SOME WONDERFUL
IS OUR MEMBERS ARE FAMILY. AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE FULLEST OF OPPORTUNITY
TO- TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR RHIANNA COULD
REUNIFICATION IF THERE. HAPPENED
TO BE LOST OR STOLEN SO I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
UNCLE. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN I CAN
I CAN DEFINITELY RELATE I I'D
LITERALLY HAVE NIGHTMARES ABOUT
OUR DOG MAY EVEN RUNNING AWAY
SO- THEY THEY THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY MEMBERS OF OUR
FAMILY- LONGER REGURGITATE THE-
TALKING POINTS I HAD WITH MR
ABLE THIS BILL. WHICH IS THIS IS
A VERY RIGHTEOUS ISSUE AND IT'S
A COMPLICATED ISSUE US A VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU. CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS IN
AND WORK WITH FOLKS WHO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL- AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD I MAKE SURE I
DIED- I UNDERSTAND YOUR OFFICES
CAN BE HELPFUL STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS- AND THAT YOU PLAN TO
MAKE SOME AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS SO. THAT'S FOR THE
PROJECT THAT- AND WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY. TO- THEY HAVE A SUPPORT
RECOMMENDED SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY- MISTER SECRETARY CALL
VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
PUBLIC'S. BERMAN I BERMAN I.
FLOOR AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I BONTA
AYE BONTA AYE CHAN AYE CHAN AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. FONG.
I'M NOT VOTING GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON MASON I IRWIN ME.
MAY I MCCARTY MEDINA SALAS SALAS
I SMITH SMITH I'D HANG. WARD
WORD I WEBER HOWEVER I. IN. THE
BILL'S OUT WITH THIRTEEN VOTES
WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER OLD
UNIVERSE WE ARE MOVING ON TO THE
LAST BILL OF THE DAY OTHER THAN
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- SO I WOULD
RIGHT NOW LIKE TO ENCOURAGE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO COME
DOWN THE ROOM WHATEVER WERE IN
ELEVEN HUNDRED AND THAT WERE AT-
MR WARD WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY FOUR. GOT A QUICK
MOTION IN A BIPARTISAN SECOND
RATE OUT WELL THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS OF THE REFORM THANK MY
JOINT AUTHORS MR LEAVE FOR
HELPING ME INTRODUCED AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY FOUR. THIS WILL
REQUIRE PHARMACISTS AND PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS TO HAVE ONE HOUR OF
C. E. THAT PROVIDES CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CARE TO MEMBERS OF THE
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY. THIS BILL
WILL HELP PHARMACISTS ADDRESS
THE HEALTH DISPARITIES FROM
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL DR TAM FAN. FARM DEAN THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION'S LGBTQ TASK FORCE
AND TAMMY TOMMY MARTIN FOR
QUALITY CALIFORNIA'S. GREAT AND
I BELIEVE- BOTH DOCTOR FAN FAN
AND- TOMMY MARTIN ARE.
TESTIFYING BY PHONE SO EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR IF YOU IDENTIFY.
THAT A FAN AND- TOMMY MARTIN
THAT BE GREAT. MISTER FANTASTIC
PARTNER LINES ARE OPEN. AND MISS
MARTIN I'M SORRY. MORNING AT THE
CHERRY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS DR CAMPAÑA AND I AM
AT THAT THE PROFESSOR CLINICAL
PHARMACY OF THE YEAR KEYCORP. I
REMEMBER TO KEEP FUTURE THOUSAND
CAN TO KEEP I TO CATCH. HI MY
APPOINTMENT I'LL BE THIRTY THE
CLINICAL. ABOUT BLOCKING DON'T
BOTHER TO COULD YOU CAN. MY
PROVIDE. MANAGEMENT THERE. FOR
LGBT CUT. AND BOTH MEN WOULD BE
. I HAVE A MANY ACADEMIC WITH
ARTICLE FUNDING TO THE- PUBLIC
OF NEGATIVE OUTCOMES THAT WOULD
KEEP TO KEEP THE PICTURE.
INCLUDING GREATER INTO OF H. I.
AND- MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
MYSTERY IN THE MATTER. TO
HOWEVER IT WOULD UNTIL I HEARD
DIRECT FROM THE HERE FOR AND
PORTABLE. NEXT TO JOURNEY THAT
HAVE BEEN THROUGH. IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE FORM TO. SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE TAX AYE DADDY. UNFORTUNATELY
AFTER ALL HER MANY MORE TO
TALKING BY SOME OF AFTER. THERE
IS. WHY THEIR HELP NEEDS ARE
CAPITAL TO MIKE. AND SUCH AS THE
NEW. AND OF AND WE KNOW WE- HOW
THEY WERE IN CHARGE INCREASE. BY
HEALTHCARE. FOR SPEAKING AT THE
ACT. AYE PART EXPERIENCED THIS I
WAS GROWING UP I AM ALSO DEMAND
WHO IN THE- TO THE- STATES A
YOUNG AGE AND HAS NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEX HEALTHCARE. EACH TIME TO
FORGET FOR THE BEING MY- THE
FIRST PART IN A BIRMINGHAM
EQUITABLE. PLAN IS COMPLEX AND
REQUIRES. ADVANCEMENT THE
PASSAGE OF THE CLUTCH WOULD BE
FIRST THAT. I WOULD BE
PROFESSIONAL AND THEY'RE PAID
WILL BEGIN TO GO EVEN. FROM THE-
CONTINUING AT. I'VE ALWAYS SHARE
WITH MIGHT BE THE- IN ADDITION
IT'S- SUPERPOWER. SOME WORKING
BILL. BEACH WERE OTHERS. THAT
THE STRETCH. I RESPECTFULLY WITH
. YOUR THE OF THIS CAR PIECE OF
MAGICALLY AT THIS TOWARD- EQUITY
AND HELP SYSTEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. THE MORNING
SHARING MY- HAVE BEEN COMING ON
THE OF. CALIFORNIA WE'RE PRODUCT
SPONSOR OF THIS. AND THE
INCREASE FOR THE BILL WAS THE
ONE FIVE NINE WE YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER. TWO NINE. AUTHORIZING
TO FURNISH TECHNICAL MANY.
WITHOUT A- VERSION. AND BILL
PASSED WITH BY. SUPPORT WE WERE
PER TO COACH. THAT WITH A RANGE
OF COMMUNITY. AND THE CALIFORNIA
. ASSOCIATION WHO IS OUR CO
SPONSOR FOR EIGHTY TWENTY ONE
NINETY THIS YEAR AS WELL. AND
THAT I THINK MY FIVE NINE EIGHT
BEING IN. THE PHARMACIST WITH.
JOINS US PUSHING THE TRAINING TO
AND THAT PHARMACY ARE IN. TO THE
TWO THAT NEED AND WANT TO PER.
EQUITABLE CARE TO ALL OF THEIR
CREATION AND LGBTQ
CLASSIFICATIONS IN PARTICULAR.
MANY OF WHOM ARRIVED PHARMACIES
BECAUSE OF LONGSTANDING BARRIERS
WITHIN THE BROADER HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WHICH WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
FROM MY CO IN IT. AND I DO KNOW
IF YOU ARE A CRITICAL ACCESS
POINT FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
FOR EXAMPLE LGBT PLUS PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT OUT TO FRIENDS OR FAMILY
BUT WHO NONETHELESS IMMEDIATE
HIGHER RISK OF HIV TRANSMISSION
OR NEED OTHER CARE OFTEN.
FEEDBACK HEARING COMPLICATION
FROM PHARMACISTS. THE EIGHTY
TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR A DAY
CRITICAL NEXT STEP IN REDUCING
THE DISPARITIES AND HEALTH AND
WELL BEING. LGBTQ BLACK PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO FACE. RESPECTFULLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ONE OF ENOUGH TO
ANY- WITNESSES BEFORE WE GET IT
TO ME TO USE ANY PRIMER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. WE DON'T HAVE ANY ON THE
LINE OR FILE. ANYBODY IN THE IN
THE HEARING ROOM DON'T SEE ANY
WANTED- OPENING UP TO ME TO ADD
ONS FOR IN SUPPORT. FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THE ROOM PLEASE GO
AHEAD MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION STRONG.
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JERRY MEMBERS WHIMSICAL WITH THE
CAL READ AS A- AND- THANKS THANK
. ANY ADDITIONAL WITH- IN SOME.
OR A- IN THE HEARING ROOM LET'S
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR ANYBODY GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR. IT'S A GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUR BRING BACK TO A
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ALREADY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND COLLEAGUES. SEEING
NONE. I APOLOGIZE HOW DO EVER
SKINNING TWO QUICK NOW IT'S FINE
IT'S FINE- I WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR INTRODUCING THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT BELL- YOU
KNOW I THINK OVER TIME WE HAVE.
I'M HAS WE'VE EXPANDED SCOPE OF
PRACTICE- WE RECOGNIZE THAT-
PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF THE
TRADITIONAL YOU KNOW PHYSICIAN-
ODD YOU KNOW HEALTH CARE SETTING
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN-
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR PATIENTS I
THINK- EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY SAID IT VERY WELL- WHEN
THEY SAID. THAT THIS BILL
ACKNOWLEDGES THE ROLE THAT
PHARMACISTS PLAY IN CLOSING
HEALTH GAPS FOR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. I'M I
WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED- TO
SEE THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CULTURAL COMPETENCY- WE
ARE ONLY DOING IT FOR AN HOUR.
AND BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO WITH
CULTURAL WITHIN CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND ALSO THAT WE
DIDN'T TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SEPARATE OR TO ALSO INCLUDE
SPECIFICS ON- THE DISPARITIES
THAT YOU SEE WITHIN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO AND NATIVE
AMERICAN AND I KNOW THAT'S A
PART IT SAYS. IT'LL BE A PART OF
IT BUT YOU CAN'T FIT ALL OF THAT
WITHIN AN HOUR- RECOGNIZING THAT
JUST WITH THE PREP IN THE PATH-
YOU KNOW HELPING COMPLIANCE WITH
THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT DIABETES
HYPERTENSION AND PEOPLE ARE
COMING IN FROM THEIR MEDICATIONS
WE'VE EXPANDED THE SCOPE FOR
VACCINES AND- WE EVEN HEARD YOU
KNOW PHARMACISTS NOW WHEN IT
PRESCRIBE BIRTH CONTROL PILLS
THAT- THAT INTERACTION. ALSO IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CULTURAL COMPETENCY YES WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT WHEN
DEALING WITH LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY BUT THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER COMMUNITY THAT
MARGINALIZE AND THAT'S OUR ARE
BLACK AND LATINO AND NATIVE
AMERICAN AND SOUTH IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN NICE IF WE HAD OR IF YOU
HAD- MAYBE BROKEN THAT OUT MAYBE
HAD TWO HOURS OF REQUIREMENT- IN
THEIR IN THEIR LICENSURE- OR
MAYBE THAT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS BECAUSE THAT.
ASPECT IS IMPORTANT AS WELL. THE
OTHER QUESTION THAT I HAD- IS TO
HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY PUSH BACK
FROM THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY
ON THE REQUIREMENT OF THE
SUBMISSION OF PROOF- VERSUS THE
RANDOM AUDIT THAT THEY USUALLY
DO. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS
DR WEBER- I'LL SAY TO ANSWER
YOUR FIRST QUESTION OR TO REALLY
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR FIRST COMMENT-
YOU KNOW THIS IS INTENDED TO BE
EMBEDDED WITHIN THE EXISTING
PRIVACY REQUIREMENTS- AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT WE CAN
FOCUS IN ON. AREAS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
AREAS IN WHICH- MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITY RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE
AS DIVERSE AS THE GENERAL
POPULATION. AND WE INTEND TO BE
AS INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE AND
ADDRESSING THOSE HEALTH
DISPARITIES PARTICULARLY IS THE
ADDRESS OF THE BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITY AND ESPECIALLY AS THE
ADDRESS WOMEN'S AND TRANS
RELATED ISSUES AS WELL. WITH
REGARD TO THE SECOND QUESTION-
WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM THAT
ORGANIZATION YET BUT I WILL
DEFER TO OUR PRIMARY WITNESS
FROM THE PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION. DR VAN ALLEN IF YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING TO THAT. NO PRESS.
OREGON QUESTION- IF I CAN JUST
CLARIFY I THINK THAT'S THE POINT
REGARDING OUR- OF PRINTING
EDUCATION WILL BE KEY I THANK
CURRENTLY HELPING A TRACK IN THE
PHARMACY CURRICULUM AS
PHARMACISTS. NOT TREATING AND-
ACCUMULATING AND THE SECOND PART
IS. FOR THE BOARD THE PHARMACY
HAVE YET TO IT HEARD ANY- PUSHED. BACK SO FAR. OKAY THANK YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S THEY THEY
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE GIVING LICENSORS. AND
THAT'S WHY THEY USUALLY DO LIKE
YOU KNOW MEDICAL BOARD AND ALL
OF THESE LARGE FORCE JUST TO
KIND OF RANDOM AUDITS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR LICENSEES. ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THEIR
REQUIREMENTS SO THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO ACTUALLY
WAIT TO ACTUALLY GET PROOF OF
EACH PERSON MIGHT BE SOMEWHAT
BURDENSOME FOR THEM AND THEY MAY
BE CONTACTING YOU AT SOME POINT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU DR
WEBER. SOMBERLY GUESTS ARE PROUD
TO BE JOIN AUTHOR ON THIS WITH
YOU AS A MEMBER WARD AND I THINK
IT'S- COURSE REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE EDUCATING OUR
PHARMACISTS ABOUT THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
BEACON K. FACES ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE AIDS EPIDEMIC IN
THAT STILL. LASSEN FOR SOME OF
THE COMMUNITY BUT ALSO JUST A
REMINDER YOU KNOW BY BY
DEFINITION THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY'S
INTERSECTIONAL WE COME FROM ALL
RACES AND BACKGROUNDS IS REALLY
GREAT THAT WE GET THIS IN AND
HOPEFULLY THERE WILL BE MORE
GROUNDWORK LAID FOR MORE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY. AND I WITH
THAT A MOVE THE BILL. ALREADY
GOT THE MOTION OF THE SECOND.
BUT I APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE NONE
THE STORE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ON THANK YOU MEMBERS AT
PLEASURE JOINING YOU THIS
MORNING AND- I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE OF ALL THANKS FOR
JOINING THE COMMITTEE IN AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND THANK YOU TO THE
SPONSORS FOR PROACTIVELY SEEKING
TO IMPROVE. THE PHARMACY
PROFESSIONS CULTURAL COMPETENCE
WHEN IT COMES TO LGBT Q. PLUS
PATIENTS AND I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI. BERMAN
I FLOOR. FLOOR I BLOOM. BLOOM
AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN.
AYE CHAN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE FONG. FONG I
GIPSON GRAYSON IT'S AN AYE IRWIN
LEE. WE AYE MCCARTY. MEDINA
SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH I TANK
. WARD I WORD AYE WEBER HOWEVER
I. THAT BILLS OUT WITH THIRTEEN
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN PERHAPS
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER WARD
THANK YOU. SO THAT IS- AND WE
HAVE TO DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
I GOT A MOTION AND SECOND ON
CONSENT. GOT TO MOTIONS AND SOME
SECONDS LOVE IT MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE ON THAT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR AB TWENTY ONE OH FIVE
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. BERMAN
HI BERMAN I FLOOR FLOOR AYE
BLOOM. WILLIAM AYE BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE CHAN AYE CHAN AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. FONG.
FONG I GIPSON GRAYSON I IRWIN
LEE MAY I MCCARTY. MEDINA SALAS
SALAS I SMITH SMITH I'D HANG.
MORT WORD AND WEBER HOWEVER I.
THEY NEEDED. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OT- THAT WITH
THIRTY VOTES WILL KEEP IT OPEN.
YEAH REALLY HANG OUT FOR A
SECOND- SO. WE NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND FOR A BI SIXTEEN FIFTY
SIX. NOW MOTION. GOT A SECOND
THIS IS PRESENTED WHEN WE'RE A
SUBCOMMITTEE- IS IT BY
AGUIAR-CURRY. YOUR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE VOTE ON A. B.
SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS BERMAN HI BERMAN I
FLOOR. FLOOR I BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NONVOTING
FONG. I'M NOT LEARNING GIPSON.
GRAYSON MASON I IRWIN ME MAY I
MCCARTY MEDINA SALAS SALAS AYE
AYES SMITH BUT NOT VOTING TANK.
WARD WORD AYE WEBER HOWEVER I.
SO THAT THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
IT NEEDS- ONE MORE WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ABSENT
MEMBERS THESE BORING YOURSELVES
DOWN HERE SO YOU CAN VOTE- SO
WHY DON'T WE- GO THROUGH AIR
MISTER GIVES AND NOT MY GUY.
WELL WE GO THROUGH- ALL THE
BILLS THAT ARE STILL ON CALL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR GIPSON.
IT CAN GIPSON AYE. MCCARTY SMITH
I CITING. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO
WEBER. LARA LAURA HI BONTA I
BONTA I'D CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE GIPSON GIPSON I MEAN MAY I
MCCARTY. THANK WORD WORD I. A.
B. SIXTEEN FORTY SIX CHEN BONTA
I BONTA AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I GIPSON GIPSON
HIGHLY. MAY I MCCARTY. THANK. AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX AGUIAR-CURRY
CHAN. GIPSON GIPSON I. MCCARTY
THANK.
SO THAT WE ARE CURRY BILL IS
OUT- THAT'S- A B. SIXTEEN FIFTY
SIX. AND IT. AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN FLORA FLOOR AYE BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE GIPSON GIPSON ELEEN MAY I
MCCARTY. THANK WORD WORD ONLINE. A. B. TWENTY FIFTY FIVE LOW
BONTA NO. ON TO NOW CUNNINGHAM
I'M SORRY. I WAS LOOKING AT THE
WRONG ONE NO PRIVATE ISLAND. SO. I FIFTY FIVE AB TWENTY FIFTY
FIVE BONTA HI. CUNNINGHAM HI
GIPSON AYE MI AYE MCCARTY. THANK. THAT BILLS OUT OF TWELVE VOTES. AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR SMITH
- CURRENTLY FOUR EYES FOR SEVEN
HOURS I'D- THAT IS BONTA NO
BONTA NOW CUNNINGHAM. AB EIGHT
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR SMITH.
CUNNINGHAM AYE OKAY. NO PROBLEM. I AM NOT VOTING MCCARTY SALAS
. THANK. AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
FIVE ARAMBULA BONTA NOT VOTING
NOT MONNING. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE GIPSON. NOT
LEARNING MCCARTY. THANK BOARD.
I AB TWENTY SIXTY FIVE VOTE
CHANGE BONTA NOT VOTING TO.
AFFIRMED.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR GIPSON
. GIPSON AYE MCCARTY THANK. NINE
I AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE
MCCARTY THANK
. NINE
SHE. MCCARTY CAN- THEY SUPPORTED
THEM THE STAFF ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TEN. AND I. AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY TWO WEBER TANG AND I. AB
SIXTEEN FORTY SIX CHEN TANG. HI
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX
AGUIAR-CURRY TANG I. AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN CORK TAINT
AND I. AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE LOW
TANG I. AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
SMITH TANG. AND NOW. A. B.
TWENTY SIXTY FIVE ARAMBULA TANG
. THING I.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE WARD
WORD I.
UNDER RIGHT NOW WITH. A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR ITEM
NUMBER FIVE BY SOME MEMBER SMITH
. FAILS. WITH FOR AYE VOTE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MCCARTY
. MCCARTY I. CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT WAS SIXTEEN VOTES. AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO WEBER MCCARTY
. MCCARTY I. AB SIXTEEN FORTY
SIX CHEN MCCARTY. YEAH JERICHO.
SIXTEEN FORTY SIX CHANT MCCARTY
. I ACT. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX
AGUIAR-CURRY MCCARTY. THANK AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN CORK
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. AB TWENTY
FIFTY FIVE LOW MCCARTY. MCCARTY
I. AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
SMITH MCCARTY MCCARTY NOW. AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE ARAMBULA
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. DOUBLES THAT
WITH ELEVEN MOST AND- AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY FOUR WARD I'M SORRY-
YEAH MCCARTY MCCARTY I. AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE HOLD
AND MCCARTY. I. THANK YOU MISS
MCCARTY AND WITH THAT OUR
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.